[Applause]
[Music]
hey ho oh my lord it's that time again
man welcome kids to another fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard
hey Deuces what's up Drive in the new
background I like it I like it is that
like a is that a like a projector screen
is that a scrim is that a wallpaper what
Real Life kid not all of us have the
fancy that you got we were like look I'm
in one of the greatest movies ever made
where do I want to be today I'm in a
Kevin Smith movie as per usual
but you know what no complaints uh how's
everybody doing out there kids
welcome back to the to the conversation
that never never stops man me and Mark
Bernard welcome my friend to the show
that never ends that's right and B
man he's not
coming
b um come uh together like it was
Thanksgiving we gather together
ask the Lord's blessing man over
the river and through the woods how was
your Thanksgiving did you do that uh uh
I did not go over any rivers or through
any woods uh I did have turkey and
stuffing and uh macaroni cheese what
that oh man it is the best Bland bird
you've ever
had like my wife does a good turkey but
it's still at the end of the day
Turkey um which means it needs all the
help it can get lot of salt lot of salt
a lot of pepper she stuffs it with ice
turkey apparently that's what
my salt going over I'm holding this in
this minded salt shaker instead of doing
it this way I got it upside down I'm
just going like this and it seems like a
particularly violent way to jerk off a
salt
shaker he's
like you know I I I of course
don't need to remind the audience that
I'm vegan not because of my politics or
because I'm woke because I almost
died many years ago and so
I went vegan and it's helped
but um since I'm safely away from bird
eating you know I if I were ever to
campaign for president one of the
platforms I would stand on is this you
can eat turkey every
Thanksgiving but you got to jerk off
that bird before you eat it that's
that's it the one tradeoff like
if you're going to kill this thing take
its life eat it cook it
presumably you got to you're
gonna take its One and Only Life you
jerk we call it the Zuckerberg
right remember that period where
Zuckerberg was like I'm only eating
I kill and then he was like I don't want
to do this anymore and then buying his
food from the grocery store same thing
here the idea is like you gotta
suck that bird off man sucking gotta
find that goblish knob and go to town
that's right and it's I guess
that works on the presumption that all
turkeys are male no female turkeys as
well man you go out the clo whatever the
[Laughter]
like you're that's it that's the price
you pay
for on Thanksgiving we see how many
people you know I wouldn't say
go vegan but probably eat a hamburger
instead I don't want to jerk off
or suck off no turkey yeah but I
will milk a cow because that that gets
me
off that's another thing now that we're
on the subject if you want my milk you
know you can squeeze my utters but how
about you give this a squeeze
man just masturbating the animal kingdom
with Kevin Mark absolutely Mutual of
Omaha presents you know what our theme
song is feed the world we still do the
Christmas
cut it off there is there an insurance
company that will subsidize this nature
show gota be I mean we don't even need
an insurance company let's just do it on
YouTube see what happens um
happened to this show remember one day
we just started doing on YouTube and now
we're
tra we're like you know General
Zod and n and what was her name
the lady Ursa Ursa that's right well
done still in there trapped still
trapped on YouTube and The Phantom
Zone of
YouTube stuck in the algorithm I've seen
some cats uh abandoning ship on YouTube
um really yeah who built like huge
audiences and worked with the YouTube
economy for a while for example I think
I saw Rooster Teeth is pulling
their going to their own website
where they're like you know it
we'll put it behind a pay wall and come
join um I I've I've seen a few cases in
YouTube where
that seems to be I'm not saying it's a
mass Exodus but you know kids are are
having different ideas we're old we're
old men kid ideas it reminds me of a
conversation that I had with um Ed
breaker like years ago where he he was
he had just launched I I want to say was
criminal maybe at at image and he was
like yeah man the the key is you go to
Marvel you work for like five or six
years you build an audience and then you
take that audience over the image where
you get to keep all the money and all
the revenue and everything you don't
have to share it with anybody but your
creative team and a little bit of image
and uh and that feels like the same
thing like go to YouTube build an
audience make it huge and then take that
audience back with you um to the place
where you get to be the person who can
capitalize and control and
maximize um ways to exploit that
audience that sounds worse than it
actually is but
still um before we go a step
further yes how many we are what it's
here we're out here in California kids
but some of you are watching from Back
East some of you are even watching from
overseas the foreign land you put out a
plate um we uh are here in Los Angeles
and and it's uh are we Tuesday yes
we're Tuesday Tuesday the 28th Wednesday
the 29th I believe somebody has birthday
is that correct that it is indeed my
birthday my friend so right now back
East it is it's 7:31 here so it's 10:31
back East yeah in an hour and a half
which this show is always like nine
hours so we will hit the East Coast
birthday which you're an East coaster so
that counts it all comes
together yeah you every east coaster who
transplants out to the West should honor
their time zone their birthday begins
whenever it began the day began and the
place of your birth that's my other
platform for running for political
office
I'm well the first one I talked about
suck off a turkey if you're gonna kill
it how do you feel about trade
negotiations let's talk about
birthdays trade negotiations you trade a
turkey's life for it blowing its load in
your mouth that's that's a fair trade
that's what I call it nuclear
proliferation nope let's talk about
turkey ju like oh I'll talk about NATO
but it's the National Association of
theater owners because I don't know if
you know this or not but I own a movie
theaters my castle like you running for
president I was like yes and for a novel
idea that nobody's ever tried I figured
like maybe I'll try to sell things at
the same
time uh but yes in in four and a half
hours uh West Coast
in what I don't know how number
work 7:30 now so it would be four and a
half hours on the on the till the Los
Angeles birthday but right 90 minutes
Mark you will officially be how old 52
years old the what the what I'm already
that age in the UK that's true it's
already my birthday thank God you
weren't born there otherwise we'd have
to honor that you'd already be the old
man I know somewhere Ryan Crest is
hopping time zon so he can drop that
ball my birthday like it's in Australia
you
guys how he Dorian Grays his by
like jumping times andone that's how he
stays young looking just steals birthday
that's a called Charlie Booker
man that's a black mirror
waiting to happen right there it is
indeed don't give that away um all
right so you're 52 years
young what uh my back's gone
out that's right we were supposed to be
doing this show live in the scum and
villain C Ina kids but uh Mark had some
back issues what happened there uh
apparently not very much because that's
the way a back works when you get to be
51 years old um it was just like one day
it didn't feel right and then the next
day it felt less right and then like
Thanksgiving day it was on my feet for
like six hours cooking and then Friday I
couldn't walk and vast amounts of pain
shooting up and down my spine and so
hobbled my ass into the ER and they said
yeah you probably just tore a slight
tear in a muscle in your back that's
been exacerbated over time and uh and
here you are have some painkillers have
some muscle relaxers take some of these
Lidocaine patches which I've got up and
down my back like an armadillo
um my mother wears Lidocaine
patches yeah she does your mom know
what's
up um she does I remember uh back when
I'm going to go see her her birthday's
coming up she turned 78 December 11th
but when I was back there last time she
was like can you grab my lioc patches my
brother too was like you got to make
sure she puts on her L Cane Patch so I
learned that word back then and stuff um
but it wasn't it wasn't like in
catty Shack where she's like will you
Loof up my stretch mark she was just
like make sure I get it she's like I
could put it on and um so they gave
you the lie to Kane that's an old I
associate it with old people because of
my mom but I'm sure it's just good for
back pain or whatever the I think
it's good for muscle pain um is that it
yeah um joint pain muscle pain but yeah
we're part of the cane gang baby lie to
cane gang me and your mom's rolling
heavy all right it works on muscles what
if you wrap one around your dick your
dick's not a muscle the way uh I feel
like it'd get numb and
hot sounds like a party that
sounds like a Tuesday night do not
threaten me with a good time son yeah
get it numb and then jerk off holy
it'll be the stranger part two right hit
it with a hammer go to town people are
like you're really not using the lioc
cane pads the way you're supposed
to like what are you doing I put them on
the inside of my hands
see
swing um so what is uh what's the latest
on the back did it return to normal or
uh it's not normal I'm at about 60% now
like I can I can stand I can walk um
being standing upright is good sitting
down is good it's the rise between the S
sitting and standing that's the pain
happens um and it's less than it's been
I'm hoping that by Thursday or Friday
I'm back to like 80 or 90% as good as
I'm going to get is 52 like who are we
kidding like nobody's gonna like put me
in coach no son you're not going in that
game never
again um well kids don't let this spooky
on Aging just
because great happens to be on the verge
of 52 and he threw his back out and they
gave him old lady pads that's not a
thing to be afraid of necessarily my
wife may have shattered her hit three
weeks ago at age 52 nothing to be afraid
of I'm sure for most people it's great
did you get your shingles vaccine
man we are getting old I've been really
thinking about it lately man in terms of
like I the I'll be honest the I've had
an
existential small existential crisis of
sorts with h hey you with uh the
collapse of the
Marvels first let me introduce you to
Jesus yeah that is a giant lap dog she's
such a dog look at this this is
birdie hi birdie birdie is over a year
old and yet she hasn't really grown
we're pretty sure she's a run her mom is
gigantic I I don't want to offend her
mother she's laying on the rug over
there but her mom is like three times
the size of this little dog um and she's
not like a little dog she's pretty you
know she's a
German say goodbye
birdie
why am I
here hey man she schs a thought on
looking into their eyes trenty look at
her she's like what what was that she
got a taste for Spotlight now
it's over um she uh I mean
look nothing will
ever replace the magic that was shecky
rest in power but this these these two
German Shepherds particularly this
little one have been like absolutely
delightful um now she's super curious
about why'd you pick me up what are we
doing now yeah what's that all about um
in any event birthday boy with a bad
back brother brother you were saying
that Marvels has got you introspective
about right you're right but but then I
got involved with the little dog and I
forgot all that see animals
are important in our lives man they
especially pets they make you
forget about um yeah I I'm you know
I started thinking like oh maybe this is
the end like you know I've enjoyed the
culture shift of the last 10 15 years
toward well of the last 30 years
the culture shifted toward pop culture
and then for the last 10 15 years
shifted very specifically toward an area
of Pop Culture uh that was well versed
in for years which would be comic book
culture and you know it's certainly not
dead James gun is making a
Superman flick and reopening the DC
Universe and um you know it sounds like
the X-Men are coming and
Fantastic 4 probably going to be we're
starting to hear casting rumors left and
right so these movies are not dead it's
not the end of the comic book movie um
you know as a lot of folks uh and even
us after we saw Marvels uh the Marvels
and and talked about that article and
variety and stuff you know let's be
honest it may slow down it may never
duplicate they may never be able to
duplicate the magic of like 10 years ago
but there's always going to be
comic book movies but that being said it
just felt like there starting to be a
shift in the in the culture um again and
that that area that I was so well versed
in is now like they're moving away from
that and stuff um and I was like oh
maybe that's the only reason that I've
been around as long as I have like maybe
my real career ended a long time ago but
I've kept myself as part of the
conversation even though I never made a
comic book movie but just being the
person about like hey man I'm going talk
about this since M rats and
if the culture shifts completely away
from comic book movies and stuff and
let's say it shifts toward politics
seems to be a very dominant
conversation right now um in a fairly
divided nation I'm ill-prepared for that
conversation and and never will be
prepared um it's just not my passion
right I go it's not like oh I can talk
about this all day because I read these
stories when I was a kid and like it's
just if the C shifts in that direction
which it feels like it really is
if it's not already there I you know
that's that's me out of the conversation
and I started going like well that's
isn't that the way of things you just
age out and maybe you know I've had an
enjoyable 30-year ride and and
you know maybe
that's maybe that's maybe
that's you know all I should be happy
for that and
gracefully uh let go
of um you
know being a chatty I don't I
don't know how else to put it it it just
felt like there was a moment or two over
the last few weeks where I was like
maybe I've outlived my usefulness you
know I'm sure there's a lot of folks
online who be like yes you know
after the first one you prick but that
was the existential crisis I was kind of
and not even a crisis where I was like
what will I do um but I've just
had a lot of time on my hands like
taking care of hippie
UPS um and and that's crawled into my
head once or twice where I'm like maybe
your time is over and everything has its
time and you had a great time
but maybe it's time for you to like step
back from
conversation anyway you know I don't
know um well I'll I'll say two things
yes I'll say the first thing is that
politics tends to EB and flow um as
we're approaching an election year it's
always on people's minds more than it's
not the last six years have been a
specifically awful kind of place in the
political Arena as divisive to your
point as it's ever been um but I think
that that is on some people's minds more
than others on some people they don't
care at all some people that's all they
care about I think that the numbers are
skewed a bit because we always seem to
be at the precipice of
authoritarianism these days um so I
don't know if it's taking the entire
oxygen out of the room and shifting it
to Politics as much as like oh well I'm
giving a little bit more bandwidth to it
but I still it is not everything I care
about it's not all of it I care about I
think that's that might be true the
other thing is that I think Disney has
had a bad few years I think Disney you
know I was reading some some box office
stuff and they and they mentioned that
like since the pandemic Disney has not
had A1 billion doll grossing
movie um where previously it had been on
a tear like every year they
would have had two or three of them if
not four or five of them boo in great
part by Marvel but even before that even
apart from that you know the liveaction
remakes of animated movies would do
great like be and the Beast did gang
musters Lion King to G buers Aladdin
made a billion dollars you know and
those haven't been performing nothing's
been performing including the Marvel
stuff and I think some of it is being
attributed and probably with good reason
to the uh insistence on Disney plus to
the putting new things on Disney plus to
the you know the pandemic desperation of
putting movies on streaming because
otherwise they weren't going to get into
the world and using that to boost a
stock price but training an audience to
know that these movies are going to come
to you at home and they're fine at home
because that's how you got them for a
whole year so why am I going to run out
and go see wish which open in like $38
million or something why am I going to
rush out to see the Marvels which didn't
open particularly well as we all know
when I know I'm going to get it in a
month um and so I think it might be a
little bit less and and it happens to
feel like superhero fatigue because
Marvel's the only people making
superhero movies at the moment so it
seems like it's all falling on Marvel
and Disney partially because Disney has
had a bad release strategy for the last
few years um we'll see what happens when
when uh when Aquaman opens um but the
success of Barbie and the success of
Oppenheimer is like no people will still
go and see a thing if you Market it well
and the movie has the goods um and if
the audience thought for a second that
either of those movies would appear on
on Max within a month and a half of
release you know we don't expect that
from Max but we do have Disney plus and
I think that's a big contributor to that
fact so I don't think that super be
fatigue particularly I think was Disney
fatigue a little bit I was trying to
explain to my kid like we over
Thanksgiving we were just having a
convers probably similar conversation to
this bro I was like and don't mind you
like this is only one aspect of what I
do as previously mentioned I don't make
comic book movies like I've a few comic
book shows and stuff but you know I've
just always been a big cheerleader of
comic books comic book culture and stuff
and have you know there's a whole side
hustle where people are like hey what
did you think and when I say hustle it
doesn't mean there's an economy to it um
in financial like some you know because
of this show every time I'm like oh my
God I love this movie people like you
shill how much is Disney paying
you and I'm like I wish but there is an
economy that comes from it even if
there's no money
where you know I I'm a part of
conversations that I wouldn't otherwise
be God bless the kind Folks at
comicbook.com who are like you know
Kevin said this about this comic
book thing that's you know a tiny
smidgen of relevancy
in an area that I really shouldn't be
part of the conversation other than as a
fan which is how I traditionally enter
the conversation I feel anyway
um it's you know I I I've seen a lot of
folks in in online in chat everyone
talking about like what's going
on um and Marvel's I think we all know I
I'm not saying I think we all know what
happen with Marvel but you know
too much Disney plus doesn't help um you
know maybe maybe take the Jerry Maguire
approach of fewer clients whatever the
it just shrink down again but the
Disney thing you know my kid was like
baffled bu she like she's a huge Disney
fan and she's like like what's going on
and I was like you here's the thing I
said I'm old enough to remember there
was a time when like Disney wasn't
dominant like there was a stretch of
years like Disney was always
classic and but like until the Lion
King well not the Lion King until Little
Mermaid like Disney was like oh yeah
Grandpa's company and like
that and like they were not the
every movie we put out there makes a
billion bucks let alone the studio that
was like we're gonna buy Star
War um so I was like it's weird to live
in a world where like for the first time
since maybe The Little Mermaid where
they had not just a bad year but like
the year where everybody's writing an
article about like the death of
Disney and and like what happened and I
know a lot of folks online are like that
what happened is they went woke it it's
not that um it it once again it feels
like too
much glut and then giving people Disney
plus gives them a place to go watch it
and they get condition to it and so
they're like why would I go see it in a
theater there seem like you know
probably what seemed like from the
outside simple fixes to these problems
but my kid could not understand there
was a time when Disney I was like yeah
man The Black Cauldron
years Rescuers Down Under yeah like
well at least some people like that but
like the you know
there were a bunch of years they didn't
know who the they were before
Touchstone remember like they were like
it we're going to make Star Wars
they made the black hole and
like they were like we're gonna make
action figures for
this movie about people on the
verge of dying with a broken down old
robot
and no real clear good or bad more like
the bad guys the black hole do we have a
figure for that no no we have one
extremely metal image at the end with a
giant fiery plant with a robot
just standing there triumphant otherwise
guy's eyes inside of it you don't know
that's meant to like maybe he a
robot you don't
know there was a time where like Disney
was like we don't know what the
we're doing and then like from a Little
Mermaid forward like bang hit bang hit
bang hit and they kind of got a formula
down and maybe that's part of the
problem um I I I don't think they're
going anywhere I think that they had a
Banner bad year and naturally
they're going to have to um and they are
reassessing and changing how they're
moving forward stuff yeah Bob iger's uh
the money quote everybody seems to be
fixating on is him saying going forward
we're about quality not
quantity it's like yeah man
and okay yeah mean fix simple plan but
it's
like will they be able to
not they've turned on the machine can
you slow the machine
down yeah I remember I remember having a
conversation with Ben about Netflix and
when I say Ben I mean Ben flick um but
he was like not Ben verine Ben verine
talking to Ben verine I was like I love
you and all that
um and I was saying like you know he he
was like look how big it is he's gone
it's going to be a public trust sooner
or later like he's like that they're
like the water department like people
are just used to he's like we grew up in
a world where it's like you had to seek
out a movie and go there and we were so
happy when we got cable TV and oh my God
the Advent of the VCR and like that
he's going but like you know at this
point like you're talking about
Generations
raised with oh I can just go to Netflix
and surf the tiles he's like it would be
like turning the water off at a town at
this point if it went away he's like it
may be a too big to fail kind of company
I mean it might be but I also remember
saying the same thing about Twitter and
you know what happened a guy bought it
and drove it into the ground um hey
sooner or later somebody's going to
write a book or or tell the real story
and this feels like trading places in
real life like somebody's got a dollar
bet couple billionaires made a Dollar
Bet to see like well let me you see what
I can take Twitter's reputation to a new
place yeah yes I guess like just like I
my kid has grown up in a world where
Disney is always dominant and yet I know
there was a time they weren't but still
I thought like
cocacola they'd go on forever
Untouchable it it's just weird to see I
mean think about it we thought
Blockbuster was
Untouchable like you know I I guess
nothing out there is Untouchable Apple's
been so dominant for the matter of years
now but it's like what happens when
everybody has the iPhone like is there
ceiling like could they be done well
they build in um artificial scarcity
right or artificial um temporariness
it's like hey so your battery is
designed to stop working as well in two
or three years so the performance in
your phone begins to go down and you
want a new phone and hey it just so
happens the iPhone 17 is out just in
time for you to have your iPhone 15
start to get shitty like they they've
made a thing it's like cars used to make
a car that could drive on the road for
20 years until they decided we
don't make money if you keep your car
for 20 years we make money if you keep
your car for 5 years and you have to get
a new car now you have to like
we can build these things to be
permanent we just choose not to because
we have to force you to buy the new
thing and they all do it I want to be
judgy but I'm part of the problem right
I may not be Ford but like I'm in the
business of Kevin Smith I'm always like
here buy new Kevin Smith and they're
like we bought every version of
Kevin Smith I'm like yeah but now he
comes with a hat they're like he always
had a
I I have Star Wars in like six
different formats because of course I do
I've still got my VHS I've still got my
laser discs I've got the first DVDs I've
got like a bootleg that has the laser
disc cuts on DVD I've got Blu-ray I've
got 4K I've got every version that you
could ever have because I'm that person
we're all that person which is what they
sort of Bank on you you don't have no
copy Oppenheimer in 4k do you CU right
now that's money I was not the one of
the lucky few who uh who got in early
crazy man um bman has been waiting
patiently to share something bman take I
was gonna say you were talking about
Netflix and all you know too big to fail
I and you know we're talking about being
old men uh my daughter just turned three
a couple weeks ago and we had had um
gosh what were we
watching uh like peacock there's a show
on peacock she's really into Ninja
Turtles right now I think Ninja Turtles
is on peacock and um I don't pay for
peacock but peacock will let you watch
with
commercials and every time a commercial
came on she would go oh no what happened
to the
turtles right I so Jen and I had to EXP
explain to her what a commercial is so
we were just in Denver at my sister's
house watching Ninja Turtles or
something and a commercial came on my
sister has a four-year-old the
four-year-old is like what's going on
it's stop working and joson was like oh
no oh no emry this is a commercial so my
three-year-old is explaining to the
four-year-old what a commercial is but
that's the world they're growing up in
it's not even an on demand world it's a
commercialist World on top of it uh
which is crazy like a 22 minute show is
22 minutes it's not 30 minutes
anymore yeah which is
crazy uh I'll also say on the old man
thing we um we had the first
Thanksgiving that I've ever had where it
was my family my brother's family my
sister's family and my brother's wife's
family but it was is all the like our
generation of people and all of our kids
so there were eight of us and I think
seven kids running around and that was
the moment the first time in my life uh
that like halfway through dinner Jen
looked at me and was like oh we're we're
the old group now and those kids who are
stealing candy from the cabinet in the
kitchen while we're all sitting at the
table that it's it's about like it's
there it's now to them we are the old
people and it was the first time that
there was no like grandmas or anything
around and I was like holy I am the
I am that's me now and my peers
are are the old people sitting at the
table and not playing air hockey in the
basement or whatever it was you're far
from the Kids Table man you're the old
man it was got cat the cradle
baby are afraid of they're like oh don't
up yeah my loan it was uh that was my
like little existential crisis over
Thanksgiving where I was like oh my God
I feel like I still feel like I'm the
like I only wear t-shirts I'm wearing a
white undershirt and sweatpants to work
today for one-on ones with my bar staff
I'm still the young cool kid I have a
backwards hat on I have a mohawk I am
not any of those things I am
middle-aged man you are you can be both
of those things at the same time and
what's nice about you know the
last well I've been in the game 30 years
now January is the 30th anniversary of
clerk's going to Sundance and my whole
career beginning and so I've I've
been I've been around for like a red hot
minute um you can you can
absolutely be both like everything has
shifted nobody looks like my parents
anymore your pictures of
yourself as a kid like if you're me and
Mark's age
particularly your our parents like this
was only 50 years ago which is like you
know half a century and but
like everyone looks so old incred ibly
old and now old people don't even look
that old like it's you know I keep
seeing articles online periodically that
are like were people just older back
then and there's always theories they're
like well in the 20s through the
50s nobody smiled in a photo because
nobody had dental care or whatever the
maybe maybe that's it and but
I you can be in your 40 how old are you
JC uh coming up on 43 you'd be insane
not to dress the way you want to dress
when you built your own business and
could do whatever the you want to
do that's something I know my father
never once considered he worked for the
for the machine well in this case the
post office and stuff like that and he
was happy to have a job but that was
just so he could pay for his family and
stuff but like you and me and Mark we're
of a generation where it's like I want
to do a thing that I saw on TV
or in a movie once that way I can dress
however the I want for the rest of
my life and not have to wear a suit if I
don't want to and stuff unless it's like
you're you know in season two of The
Bear and I wear Suits now yes
I the uh is that is is hold on is that
not is Forks not the best episode of TV
you've seen in a long time it was it was
absolutely wonderful that was the which
one is that is that that's Richie going
to to stage at the fanciest restaurant
in Chicago wonderful especially like the
last scene one of the last scenes with
him and um Olivia Coleman where they're
just like let's just have her come in
and drop
science It's a Wonderful series
absolutely and it's if you've ever
worked in a restaurant it really hits
home if you've ever worked as a team
like you know a lot of film and TV
people like the show because it reminds
you of production a bunch of
personalities forced to work together
and create a thing and thing that just
blew my mind watching the show I I love
both seasons but season one I love more
than season two um only by this much
more I'm not saying like Season Two
Season Two is absolutely wonderful um
but I thought it was Brave as to
build all of season
one and then I don't want to spoil it
and then do what they do at the end of
season one and that's what predicates
season two like most TV shows be like if
it's ain't broke don't fix it kind of
quick so once again FX just Adventure as
um it it's reminds me of Ted
lasso but with less dialogue perhaps I
don't know how to describe it like they
if you you feel good watching the
show um but it's not like um and I I
don't want it like I don't know how to
describe it like Ted lasso has that
Richard Curtis Feelgood kind of
thing and this
has more of
a
um you know like Richard link later
feel-good kind of thing it's just smart
I think it it it trusts the audience a
little bit more than Ted lasso does
agreed you know and and because there's
there's setups and payoffs of things
like there's and again we this is not
just me c talking you guys just happen
to be here but there's the episode when
when Marcus goes to like whatever
Switzerland I think or Sweden to learn
with that guy wonderful episode where
Standalone with this one dude learns to
bake in a kitchen that is nowhere near
anything else you barely see anyone else
and he's talking to uh to to what's his
face the guy who was in um names are
escaping me but he was he was the the
who the is it he's in Guardians 3
the dude was all gold oh uh will polter
will polter um and will polter tells
this story about how he's like listen I
thought that I was the best chef in the
world and I conducted myself that way I
pushed myself and I thought that I was
as good as as I could be and the chef
comes into the restaurant that I'm
working and shows me what good really is
I thought I could compete with him I
thought I could keep up with him and I
just couldn't and it's it it freed me to
then be the person that I was going to
be because I didn't have to be the best
I could just be as good as I could be he
drove me he pushed me he he he
accelerated my development um and I'm
glad that he was there and they never
say who that other Chef was until like
four episodes later Richie's walking
down a hallway and you see will poter
and you see Jeremy Ellen White
in a picture together and they never
call attention to it and they never even
mention it in dialogue but you then know
oh it was him he was the guy
and like Ted lasso would have made a
thing about that and I don't mind like I
love Ted lasso we talked
I'm not saying and it's not like one
over the other or one you know somebody
in the thread was like the the bear is
the ATI Ted lasso and and I disagree I
think they they're very similar in as in
as much as they celebrate Humanity like
there's a moment in the bear where um
who's the lady in the kitchen who
finally puts on the oh yeah I don't
remember her name but like when when
Sydney asks her to be like would you
would you be my chef to cuisine
don't you're gonna make me cry
because it was like oh my it's a
beautiful human
moment just hold the camera on this
actor yes
and it that that moment
alone the performance on the actor's
face worth a billion dollars because you
actually feel oh my God this person
feels seen and appreciated and like it's
quiet it's not like they don't build a
whole dialogue thing around it but one
of the scene like where she went and
sang what is it Freddy Fender I'll be
there before the LA The Next Teardrop
Falls that she does it like the karaoke
night was a a stunningly beautiful scene
and it's just a person singing
but it's cut so insanely well as the
room responds to her and she has this
like wonderful moment where
she's
like she's even this late in her life I
mean she's got like kids and stuff like
that
she's finding
appreciation like and and that's Ted
lasso has that going for it as well like
quiet Humanity or you
know not so quiet Humanity just
Humanity how precious that is and it's
really really wonderful I saw somebody
in the thread going like I can't find it
now but they were like look I've worked
in restaurants for 10 years this Show's
overrated it's not necessarily
like you know hey man restaurant people
only it is a show about restaurants but
it's
like and I'm not taking it away and
saying like it's not really about
restaurants naturally it's about
restaurants but like Ted lasso it's
about shining a light on each character
and their humanity and these people even
when they bicker are deeply
connected um
and are fond of one another you know
what I'm saying like they're a family
even though they're not they created
this family and is really well done was
an easy watch man yeah supery like 28
minute episodes they completely just
skate by and like when they're great
they're amazing when they're just really
good it's still really good TV
100% yeah um should we talk about some
other TV shows that we're on we don't
have an ad this week so we don't have to
pause for the cause we can just roll all
content
kids yeah you saw a lot more than I did
the the
the the bear uh is the the same like uh
the bear I mean rather is the thing that
I watched that was brand new um I don't
know if I watched anything
else new but you have I have I've been
seeing some because some of it was
like you know a week off and not going
anywhere not doing much being
indisposed with my back not being able
to go out there and wrestle
alligators anymore so i' just been
sitting on my ass a bit um but I saw the
the first two maybe three episodes of
Monarch Legacy of monsters oh that's the
Apple TV show yeah tied in the Godzilla
movie The King Kong movie yeah and I I
kind of dug it you know like it
it's doing the thing that I always say
that I don't want which is in I don't
want any people in my monster movies
just G me 30 minutes of monsters
punching each other in the face and I'm
good um but this is yeah I mean we we
all saw Godzilla versus Kong and was
like I don't care about these humans I
just want to see these two
fight people who are traditional fans of
of like the Godzilla movies and stuff
maintain that the human part is
incredibly important and I understand
what the argument is but you know as
somebody who grew up on on the Godzilla
movies on the 430 movie where they were
cut way down to like one in length I can
appreciate the like let's just watch him
fight yeah like is less about that it's
more about it's all the people talking
stuff it's it's all of the be like they
they give you the big like Beauty shots
of Godzilla destroying San Francisco as
sort of a backdrop for one of the
characters and so you get some of that
in there but it's mostly this sort of
it's not a Time hopping thing like
there's no Doctor Who's in it um
but uh but it does sort of skip through
time periods so that you get the neat
trick of Wyatt Russell and Kurt Russell
playing the same character about 40
years apart that's dope that's which is
kind of dope like that you can
do that without having to deage anybody
or or up AG somebody it's like no just
get father and son they sound the same
they look the same it's a good idea
right there I buy it um and so like it's
it's a little X Files um you know
there's we got to find what what's
happening there there's a thing in in
this well in in in Japan that somebody
found in 1975 and now we found the film
and the file footage of it in in 2015
what is it it's all a big mystery thing
but the characters are kind of cool the
world is pretty neat a world that
understands there's a Godzilla you know
so there's like Godzilla evacuation
routes in Tokyo and and there are
bunkers that you can go hide in if
there's a Kaiju sighting somewhere like
it's it's smart and it's cool and and
and it moves pretty quickly you don't
have time to get bored even though you
don't see a ton of Godzillas um it was
developed um by uh by two folks a guy
named Chris black and then Matt fraction
of comic book Fame is the other guy who
who put this one together um you know
the cast is good it knows what it is it
is not asking too much of you it moves
fast it's a mystery show and the Mystery
seems interesting um I'm kind of digging
it and how often do you see monsters um
you know there's some version of a
monster that like they're I think
they're holding the giant godzilla big
ass Kaiju thing for later in the season
but you see kind of smaller versions of
monsters you see a couple of flashbacks
like Skull Island and some big monster
attack like it's you you get a
taste every episode but they're they're
saving it um WTF rocks said Godzilla
minus one this weekend only in theaters
so the Godzilla movie from uh too right
yeah yeah it's it's sort of a a
reimagining of that first Godzilla 54
movie of like is that what it is yeah
it's back stunning ratings like I think
it's at 100% or some close to that yeah
but that comes out I guess you could see
it here this weekend only yeah I think
it opens on the second or the first
um but yeah I I can't wait to see it I'm
going to be in San Francisco this
weekend so I might have to pass what are
you doing family or business I am uh
taking taking Splinter to another Film
Festival which one up in the bay it's
called another hole in the head Film
Festival so those who don't know Mark
directed a movie um Splinter and
he's been around and this is yet another
place he gets to take it man well
Another Place Another Place and I think
after after this weekend the next place
you can see it is on the uh Cru of
skew that's right good plug we
don't have a sponsor so Cruiser skew
kids Jane Sol Bobs cruises.com
um it is coming you can't stop it be on
a boat with me and Mark Jason Muse Jason
Lee Brian o' Hollin Jeff Anderson all
your favorite stars from clerks and M
rats eth every night we got a movies
yeah look at that graphic look look at
those y it's dripping and
everything that's right dripping because
people are creaming over the
opportunity to go to sea with all your
favorite folks right here folks
there it is um Cru es skew coming in
February of 2024 right around the Ben
christas
coming still some cabins left man we're
I think we're at
something almost 80% sold at this point
so yeah it's pretty good it's going to
be fun man 3,000 of us at Sea
together doing podcasts showing the mov
when when are you showing the movie I
think it's Sunday I think it's Sunday we
we we dis we we embark on the cruise on
Friday we're Saturday at se and I think
Sunday is a bunch of on the boat as
we pull into the Bermuda the I don't
even know don't talk to me I'm not the C
Stu the captain stubing of this
particular Adventure
but are you the Julie uh I'm the
bartender I
I'm I didn't want to immediately assume
you'd be the Isaac but you know who I am
I'm the I'm the the L RS the guest star
who shows up on Theon Isaac's dad Isaac
shows up on that episode and Isaac's
like Dad it's you with a mustache and
runs in the
family and he's like you're a
war that's
[Laughter]
him
that's
um who was I just doing one in a million
chance of a lifetime um is that Teddy
pentag no is it it's
uh
Graham oh my God I hate when I have
these old person moments but Lou RWS is
you'll you'll never find another long as
you live someone who cares about you the
[Music]
oh my God you're I'm you're bringing to
mind visions of my mother making eggs on
a Sunday morning and
singing along to Lou Ross yog GNA miss
my Ling you gonna miss my love she was
doing Harmony and yeah that
that for me is like driving in my
mother's like 197 mobile Larry Graham is
one in a million
one in
million so yes uh Monarch Legacy of
monsters totally worth a watch um I've
seen the first five episodes of squid
game The Challenge are you familiar with
Squid game The Challenge so they made
this squid game and it was all about how
you know
this is isn't it cruel that
these rich people watch these poor
people or people that need money or
destitute or last you know chance folks
compete for money how cruel and
bloodthirsty and then their takeaway was
like let's do it in real life let's do
it for reals let's build this all in
some studio in England no one will get
killed mind you but you know yeah like
we're still gonna do red light green
light we're gonna put squibs on
everybody so like when they get that's
what it is so you could get shot but
it's just a squib it's just a squ still
that's like that's a big deal
yeah and it's it's black ink not red so
it's like oh they didn't get shot they
just got eliminated they got in they got
Inked um it's still it's still pretty
good though no
it it is like I'm kind of like
hooked on it a little bit not quite in
the way that I was in in the in the in
the scripted version of it which is in
infinitely superior but it's like it's
it's Survivor that's all it is and if
you cast it well um and and you don't
know who's going to go and still do the
thing where like we start with 456
competitors week two 275 CU we eliminate
half of them in red light Greenlight the
next one like you know we're losing 30
and 10 and 15 and 20 chunks and there's
a couple new games that are interesting
and they're not clearly killing people
so they've got to invent other games
that don't involve death but it's it's
still pretty riveting um I gotta
say I can't you're you are a mystery my
friend if I had to lay money on I'd be
like no way Mark likes this I yeah it
just I don't know it's it's evocative
it's just evocative of enough of the
show that I'm like you know what okay
and there are awful enough people that
you want to see get their just reward
and then there's people that seem
totally chill who you want to see
advance in the game like it's it's every
reality show um just a little bit cruler
and that these people are like
sequestered Big Brother style in a
dormatory with 400 beds
and they're living together without able
to see the sun without knowing what time
it is not getting enough food forming
shitty little alliances that always get
blown up because the game is ruthless
enough like it's it's pretty good man
what is the what's the top prize is
there only one it's still like $4
million like and it's like every time a
person gets kicked out they add $110,000
to the to the pot and so like yeah I
think they're now at $3.8 million for
the 78 people remaining and there's five
more episodes of the show like I don't
know man I'm in it to win it um the
other show that I've seen on the Netflix
is Scott Pilgrim takes off how's that
animated right animated looks very much
like the Brian Leo Ali comic books yeah
um it uh it is it all the voices from
the people in the movie correct
everybody from the movie came back like
top to bottom Soup To Nuts
um the first episode plays very much
like the beginning of the movie and the
beginning of the book that you remember
like Scott Pilgrim well meaning kind of
lay about you know unambitious uh
slacker who's a bass player of a band um
he meets this girl who delivers a
Netflix DVD and he falls in love
with Rona flowers and then he goes to
him and his band are G to put on a
showcase and they're gonna either be
famous or not and then after the first
episode um you'll dig this Scott Pilgrim
seems to die
and why would I dig this it was very
evocative it reminded me quite a bit of
a thing and uh and like the rest of the
show the season spoilers people who
haven't seen it um but it's been in the
top 10 of Netflix for quite a bit so I
have a feeling you've all seen it it's
about Ramona Flowers trying to figure
out what happened to Scott Pilgrim she
doesn't think he died she's trying to
find out what did happen and it's a
complete version from what you think you
know of Scott Pilgrim if you were a fan
of the books of the movie it is not that
at all and it's a bold swing um
for creators to just say you know what
I've already made the book once we made
the movie that's faithful to the book we
don't need the same thing a third time
so let me reexamine this work and find a
different way into it and go deeper than
we've ever gone before and come to it as
a grown ass person like Brian Leo Ali
was in his 20s when he wrote and Drew
the com comic books and now he's an
older man who has a completely different
perspective on the world and revisiting
these same characters with that new
perspective is actually really
fascinating to watch um I really dig it
um I uh I think if you're a Scott
Pilgrim fan I think you will dig it as
well if you're not hey whatever it's a
it's it's a fun good 28 minute watch um
but yeah man I really I really enjoyed
it and I also appreciate that like you
know Ben DAV rinsky and and briy Amal
who were the executive producers
creators and sole writers of it like
there's no second season this is what
you get like doing it once to one yeah
they were like we don't have an idea for
another one if something occurs to us in
a couple years maybe we'll come back to
it but this is the story enjoy it is
Edgar involved Edgar's an executive
producer of it um you know and I think
lots of the like working title people
Universal people or whomever like all of
the names that are on it are names that
are familiar from the credits of the
movie but yeah man it's super it's super
entertaining really really fun um I
watched uh the new season of Fargo
there's like two episodes may be three
at this point but I watched the first
two yeah John Ham and his Pierce nipples
and yeah and uh Juno Temple doing like a
really um Fargo
esque
accent um but that's been really good
yeah I've enjoyed it so far it's only
two Good
Times um John Ham to anything at
one point he gets out of the hot tub man
and they show him from behind and
and I'm like is that what a man looks
like
so far away so far
away he's been talking about I want to
be in a Marvel movie yeah played Mr
Sinister back in the X-Men and but
now lot of people are like
and the the John Ham's Dr Doom rumors
begin indeed like i' that one I would
take that I would take John Ham as Dr
Doom take John Ham as anything take John
Ham on Ry man John Ham's John Ham
yeah take that take it where here there
whereever right under here I'd
put it under my
arm um the last thing that I saw was uh
Napo Ridley Scotts Napoleon holy
how much time do you have on your hands
isn't this movie like 19 hours it's
actually not that long it's like 237
it's oh so it's shorter than Oppenheimer
yeah shorter than Oppenheimer shorter
than killers of the flower Moon um it's
okay put that on a
poster Hey sir
Ridley I
mean okay um yeah it's not awesome it uh
I mean it looks amazing cuz really knows
how to shoot a thing and he can still
Marshall troops on battlefields like
nobody's business and but
like it it reminded me a bit of the
prequel trilogy in that it's a story
that seems to be all about and hinges on
us buying a
romance like either you believe the
Anakin Skywalker and Padme are for
real and it's the the love story
to end all love stories and when he goes
evil it breaks people's heart and she
dies on the table of a broken heart like
you have to buy all that the rest of it
doesn't hold and it's not great you know
um this is a story about Napoleon
bonapart and Josephine his wife and
their great love that that emboldens him
and leads him to Greatness and like I
never thought that they were in love I
don't know what they see in each other I
don't know what they do for each other
um and so every time you have a scene of
the two of them being married you're
like like why why a why am I here B why
are they together and C why is she the
thing that makes him great um I don't
know I mean it's the same thing we
always talk about it's the I don't know
why he does what he does other than
history says he has to do what he does
like why is he driven to to to become
the greatest General in all of France
like what in his childhood made him want
to do that what armed him for this is he
just a genius was he T like all of these
things they don't care about and so it's
a lot of it's like weed IIA film making
and that 1817 we cut off Maran tet's
head 1819 it's the first thing in this
part of France and 1823 he's named The
First Council
and it's very like it's very chapter
driven like I either need it to be
smaller and we're going to focus on one
part of this dude's life or bigger and
we're telling miniseries and we can do
all of the things but this weird version
just doesn't just doesn't
hit just doesn't hit uh
um I don't yeah I I'll it'll be good at
home I was gonna say I'll wait till it's
on Apple TV and I'm like Napoleon and in
will'll go down that road uh I saw the
French critics were like this is
sheet they really like went after
it was like what the um yeah I
guess the French of course have a little
more skin in the game yeah over here
people are like hey rley Scott does it
again and over there they're like
did it again he did
and I thought Ridley's response was
like who gives a Ridley's like I'm
sorry I made that movie 12 Movies ago
I'm I'm up here in the future this is a
guy who does not stop like just makes he
makes I think he makes more movies than
Tyler Perry every
year and Tyler POS he's he's just I
mean like I I I I won't be that director
when I get old and and not because I'm
like they won't let me which will
probably be the case but I I can't
imagine having that much energy where
you're like let's do another one let's
do another one let's do another one come
on line them
up but good for him man just
like you know it reminds me I tell the
story all the time but like Jason wman
was on the podcast years ago
and he said that the best piece of
advice that his father uh Ghostbusters
director Ivan wman gave him was make as
many movies as you possibly can he said
after Ghostbusters I got precious and I
wouldn't make any flicks because I was
like I'm waiting for the next
Ghostbusters he's like you know how
often Ghostbusters comes along not a lot
he's going so I I he said in retrospect
I wish I had made more movies better
chance that more of them you know would
be good like you know yeah some of them
might have been bad but like you know
right now I you know I just feel like
God I wish I'd made more such a great
like piece of advice if you're a you
know that's your calling if you're a
director but it feels like Ridley Scott
is just like oh yeah I got that advice
years ago I'm just I'm just going what
else you got for me he's like I'm a
filmmaker that's what I do one of the
greatest living filmmakers and and
of course like what am I what
else am I gonna do yeah get on stage and
do quas stand up like you
jackass I saw the trailer for
Ferrari which was very very uh endemic
of of the same um Napoleon problem where
I'm looking at the Ferrari trailer and I
felt a lot like uh like Ian Malcolm in
Jurassic Park like uh excuse me are you
gonna have any Italians in your Italian
movie like I see that also a Ridley
Scott movie no it's Michael man but it's
like Adam Driver and and Penelope crew
and Haley Steinfeld and no shaying
Woodley and like are there any Italians
in your movie about Italian car racing
like do you have any french people in
your French people movie why is
everybody speaking with a British accent
they're all supposed to be French find
some French people they're
Star Wars
Europeans yes Lord
Vader um yeah yeah yeah that's it's
wild
um somebody asked about
um Nicholas Cage movie my kids saw it
she loved it yeah what's the the dream
dream something yeah uh don't remember
what the last name is like it's a good
name it's a good pun name but I can't
remember um he's out there still
clearing the air about Superman you know
people ask now like what do you mean
he's like I what I said like I literally
they told me to like look out at A Dying
World and say nothing but just show it
in your eyes and he's like and then I go
to a movie theater and like you know
there's well I don't he didn't say that
part but he's like but there's a whole
scene that I didn't do and he's
you know his whole thing is not like
dream scenario I don't know if AI they
used AI or not he's like the point is
you know there's a contract you enter
into and like you're they say you're
going to do this and you're like okay
I'll do that and then you sign up and
he's going and then they made me do
that I was wasn't even aware I was going
to do yeah I mean which it's not they
didn't use AI to do it but that is part
of the AI
conversation which is you scan my body
my face and my voice do I then have
control of what you do with that digital
representation of me um I did it
specifically for you to make this
dinosaur movie and then I find myself in
a science fiction Space movie I
didn't know that that's what I was doing
you've you got to tell me what you're
making me do um yeah which seems like a
reasonable request yeah like I didn't
read that and go like oh actors I was
like yeah like this kind of makes sense
and you know he wasn't like Andy
muset and and his and Barbara mushet and
he was just like look I like them both
they're great people but like I you know
I just didn't know that's what was I was
going to be doing yeah um and
technically it's like well you didn't do
it because of was big old CG effect he's
like well that's the point is like they
made it I'm supposed to be that guy and
I'm fighting a giant spider and then I
turn around it is me he's like it's me
but yeah it's like I read the script
that you had I signed on to it based on
that script and then I show up on set
and I do what you tell me to do and then
what appears is nothing that was in the
script that feels a bit like at the very
least dodgy and at its Zenith
fraud yeah it also feels
like it doesn't necessarily mean he
would have been like I ain't doing that
but he's just like just tell me
you know
like let me know all I was told is I'm
gonna look out and look sad he's
like all a sudden I fighting
giant spiders
with yeah or or if there's a change tell
me there's going to be a change by the
way we I know we shot this we told you
going to this in post we went a
different way just so you know what to
expect with what we did with your body
but uh yeah
weird weird so you're you're you know
you're like the
Napoleon home watch for you you know I I
we were choosing my wife and I were
choosing between Napoleon and the The
Hunger Games prequel um and I feel like
we chose poorly um not that I and I
wanted to see Napoleon on a big screen
we saw it on an iMac screen and again
like Ridley can frame a thing like few
other people can like it looks great but
I kind of wish we had chosen the other
one which I hear is pretty decent which
one did you oh the hung song birds and
snakes instead you were like it
let's go to homework the movie let's do
it let go to wall uh you should be
reading lemand my friend they would have
told you what to do it is
nail it is sheet that's right they got
they got their own word for
Sheet um what else you watch anything
else we all um I think I think that's
that's sort of where I am am I watching
anything
else um no not really not really I'm
watching I'm catching up with bodies on
on your
recommendation um which you know I like
I don't love but I like it the the the
gimmick is is enough to keep me going
um no man it's been it's been a lot of
like Great British baking show which is
perhaps one of the greatest reality TV
shows to ever be made in the history of
Television I know you had a weakness for
the reality genre um I I don't have a
deep one um I I skitter along the
surface um I watch Like Amazing Race
because it's like a travelog um I watch
great Beard's baking show because it is
the most reaffirming of humanity show
that you will ever ever watch they are
the best people in the world and because
there's no prize money because there's
nothing at stake Beyond like hey you're
Star Baker this week they help each
other they support each other they kind
of hug each other when it goes bad like
it's it's it's Cooperative competition
if that's even possible um and they're
all the sweetest people on the
planet and so that was a pandemic watch
when like I needed a thing to you feel
good about and watching British people
with questionable teeth make pretty good
food and care for each other in the
process was uh was was the bomb that was
needed
um uh they've asked in chat a few people
are asking about have we watched the
bass Reeves show not yet I haven't seen
it yet um I am not a Taylor Sheridan TV
person um that's that's from the same
guy that did
yellow stones and uh the Tulsa King and
special ops lioness and he makes the
shows that people watch the shows that
actually have double digit ratings and
stuff it makes the shows that makes
Paramount Network and I think peacock is
something it's streaming on whatever it
is but he's the engine of of the
Paramount streaming
platform I haven't watched it yet I like
David O Yello but I haven't I haven't
buckled in yet they asked if we watched
The Curse I think we talked about it
last time but yeah the curse is I
haven't seen the curse yet you haven't
seen it watch it for the tiny
dick scene in episode 101 you'll just be
like wow John hams nipples tiny dicks in
the curse you do anything now nowadays
on
TV B hey it's bam man what you got uh I
saw something but it wasn't on TV it
was probably now keep in mind I have
traveled the world for Star War
conventions I've traveled the world for
Kevin Smith shows and Jay and Silent Bob
get old shows um I I own scum and villan
Cantina I have seen some nerdy in
my day uh last week I went and saw a
band called cybertronic
spree and they were opening for a band
called Mac
Sabbath cybertronic spree dresses up
like
Transformers from the 1986 Transformers
animated movie and play 80s songs and
songs from the soundtrack of that movie
so they play like an 80s metal version
of the Transformers theme song and then
they played like the Mortal Kombat theme
song and then they played the Power
Rangers theme song and it was awesome it
was I was like
six years old watching because they have
it's all foam Transformers costumes but
you can't see their eyes like their eyes
are have like like blue Oakley oneway
mirrors on them so you never get it's
not even like Chewbacca where you can
see like real eyes in Chewbacca these
are like
animated you know they people but
because you can't see their face faces
you're like complete suspension of
disbelief um and then after they finish
playing a bunch of songs from a movie
that's almost 40 years old the a band
called Mac Sabbath comes on and it's a
Black Sabbath cover band that changes
all the words to Black Sabbath songs to
fit a fast food theme and they dress as
Ronald MCD Donald is the lead singer and
Grimace is the guitar player the
Hamburglar is the
drummer and there was probably a
thousand people there and
like I mean you might anytime you go
into scum and villainy there there will
be some normal people there there's not
a single normal person at this concert
not one like every single person there
like you could go up to and just be like
you know in season 3 of the Transformers
episode 18 when hot rod does this and
they'll be like I know I couldn't
believe he said this and then this like
it was like the deepest nerd like when
we were kids and you'd see somebody like
wearing Like a Star Wars t-shirt in like
1990 and you're like oh you you remember
that space movie when it's not cool it
was a room full of those people like see
it how can people see it they are uh it
was the end of their tour was in LA and
they
um and then they drove they from Toronto
so Toronto Toronto a dot yeah Canadian
robots um it was incredible I guess they
play Dragon Con every year and a couple
other like
conventions don't don't skip it it's it
was amazing and then the thing that blew
my mind is they came to scum and
villainy that was a Sunday night on
Monday they came and sang karaoke at
scum and villan which was
crazy uh so I got to hang out with hot
rod and RC from my favorite childhood
movie at my bar which was awesome uh but
yeah if you ever buy a bar yeah
everything cool happens when you buy a
bar and uh yeah and if you get a chance
to see robots playing 80s hair metal
take it it is
incredible and the nerdiest thing you'll
ever do thank you in chat they're asking
us Blu-ray addict is like are you guys
looking forward to the This Is Spinal
Tap sequel yes uh Rob Riner mentioned
that there might be a spinal tap sequel
I'm of course if if anything moves
forward I'm there for that I Love This
Is Spinal it's one of the new stories um
which we can jump ahead into but he's
like they're shooting in
February I didn't get past the headline
holy really all right well hold
hold that thought um Brian Christian
asks Invincible season two uh well he
says he doesn't ask he says is good I
haven't seen it yet but I did watch half
of uh gen
V wonderful haven't seen either but I'm
gonna I'm gonna get around to it I
promise really really great companion
piece series for the boys extends the
universe all the acting is topnotch is
good stuff man it's like the X-Men while
we wait for the X-Men or the X-Men if
they could shrink tall shrink
real small and grab onto a giant
dick um which is a setpiece in spoilers
episode one I think maybe as you do yeah
it's uh totally worth watching um Mike W
say is blue-eyed Samurai Mark talked
about that last week or the week before
and loves it loves it's it's uh it
remains phenomenal I started watching it
again because I wanted my uh my son and
my wife to watch it and uh it even a
rewatch just continues to yield new
wonders and glories um cannot recommend
it highly enough I still think that Jen
would like it potentially more than you
would good to know we're looking for
super watch we've been you know she's
well she's been on the couch has
previously spoke about my wife shattered
her hip and had emergency hip surgery uh
but uh we went to the doctors yesterday
and he's like your X-ray looks fantastic
and your wound looks great and you're
walking here with a cane normally people
are still walking with a walker so you
know you're doing great so you can sleep
in the bed she'd been sleeping on the
couch for like three weeks and the couch
a coughin he's got like three
High sides and so if you're in
there you just feel like you're
dead so she got to come back to the bed
last night but that little dog
that I showed you the little ger
Shepherd she's been luxuriating in the
bed with me for the last three weeks and
he was baffled by like who the is
this I was like that's your mother like
what do you mean who is this evicted
yeah who had your time and
so you know I was real worried that
she would hit Jen's wound and but
the dogs are intuitive they're like we
know to stay away from that instead she
just took up most to my side of
bed sorry about that man these are dog
owner problems
kids problems in the world to have um
but in chat everyone Mark is going nuts
and I assume most of those folks of
course are from overseas wanting to know
are we gonna talk about Dr Who because
our art work is done by the the Great
Dark Nate returns Nate Gonzalez um is
very Doctor Who themed and of course
they just dropped the new first of three
parts of uh it's Doctor Who's 60th
anniversary is that what it is yeah yeah
so they they've done like three special
kind of mini movies that I think they're
putting up on Disney plus the new home
of Doctor Who is
that really yeah yeah they they they
bought the rights from BBC America um
who had then bought the rights from PBS
originally um from the UK so does their
deal it's just like oh this is where it
airs domestically or like that's where
it airs world I think domestically I
think in the
US in the UK it's still the BBC it's
still the BBC I'm not sure if it's one
two three or four um but it's definely
it's on the be as they say as they say
um in this David Tenon came back uh
replacing Jody
Whitaker but uh spoilers I mean I didn't
watch it so we're not gonna go deep on
it and did you watch it yet no I haven't
watched it yet either I'm the only
person who likes doct who in my house so
I need to sneak away and find the time
to watch in the closet timey Wy if you
will um but I read a piece that
indicates that
um all is not as it would
seem it RAR is um but of course uh who's
the writer that came back that everybody
loves I believe it's Russell T Davies
yeah him and David Tenant coming back
um I've I've seen a lot of love for it
and I've seen some people accusing it of
being woke or whatever yeah I mean
they're they're they're transitioning
into the new Doctor Who will take over
in the next series um played by uh shudi
gatwa who's an a British African actor
all right so everybody knows this yes
that is not a surprise so that it's not
not going to be David Tennant going
forward right like David Tenant is back
and I think there will be some version
for the 60th anniversary where all of
the surviving doctors appear on screen
at once which they seem to do time and
again where it's like hey here's Matt
Smith and maybe they'll get eckleson
who's never wanted to do it before and
you know there's still some of the older
actors who were still alive who like
Sylvester McCoy I think is still alive
and Paul McAn and all these folks who
like yeah we'll pay you some money come
up to to to Cardiff
and spend a day in the in the
Tardis are all words that mean something
if you're into Doctor Who yes no
doubt it is
um um is this the beginning
of the new
doctor well the Disney
doctor um I I don't believe I mean I
don't think Disney plus is part of the
production of it at all I think they
literally are just the distributor for
for the thing I think it still gets
funded by the BBC and whatever
independent um financing they have
overseas so I don't I mean the people
who want to find a reason to hate it
will call it the Disney doctor in the
same way they call the Star Wars they
don't like Disney Star Wars um but I
don't think those two things are quite
analogous but there will be people who
hate it because it's a black dude
playing the doctor um because that
happens uh
I you know I I've you with the show
far more than I do but I've with
the show in the
past and I don't want to start a
debate and
but I I always thought this show is
fairly
Progressive it always has been line like
I mean I hesitate to use the word woke
but like when somebody was like they
went woke I was like yeah
decades ago like yeah the same thing
about Star Trek it's like I don't like
this new woke Star Trek it's like it's
been woke since 1965 I mean that's
that's the it's its whole life is
predicated on like here's some new ideas
about bringing to people together in the
future and it's built into the
premise and if you don't like it you've
actually never liked
it um so uh will you be watching it of
course you I will I will like I I I I am
not a like in the wool Doctor Who fan um
but I've I've I have with it in
the past I with some doctors more
than others I I with David Tenant
and Matt Smith more than I with
uh um Jody Whitaker or um Peter kaliy um
but I generally like I like a good
Anthology like I think it's a great
premise for his show I think it's a
great engine for for story and uh and
I'll always kind of tune in and see what
they're doing and how they're doing it
and when it's great it's as good as
anything else on TV
um so yeah man I'm going to I'm going to
I'll dip my Tally Wacker into a into a
Dr pool uh uh sounds so filthy
and sexy uh will Wilkins you know um
good old will um hosts net heads if you
don't with Nee heads why not um he
is a a huan and he says yes it has been
very Progressive most under Russell T
Davies and he's back
um but and he's a fan he also said Mark
don't with doctors
man well here's my problem with
doctors I make a doctor's appointment
and if I'm late for my doctor's
appointment by 15 minutes they will
charge me for the time of the doctor's
appointment and cancel the appointment
on me if I show up on time that doctor
is not in to see me for an hour and a
half usually they can be late but I
can't be late who like who is the
customer here and who is who is the the
the provider like the customer's right
like be here when I'm here
preach old man now shake your hand at a
cloud get off my
lawn um uh somebody wrote um Mark Ashley
in chat wrote no Star Trek was never
shoving the allegory down your throat
um I really because I always felt as a
kid you know I used to like when start
horrible to admit but when Star Trek
came on like I would turn it off because
I was like this is too when Frank Goran
is playing two guys uh twins who like
have one side of their faces is white
and one side is black and the other ones
the right side is white and the left
side is black and they're like I hate
him because he's got black on the wrong
side of his face like yeah man it's
about race like half the twilight zone
is about race and privilege and sexism
classism communism like nism that's what
the Twilight Zone was about Star Trek
was too you guys just because it was
costumed up and there were laser beams
but when William Shatner kisses
Aura that's a big deal with aura
being on the bridge and and having a
place of prominence that's a big
deal with an Asian dude is the the pilot
of your Starship it's a big deal
you know because you were nine and
didn't see it doesn't mean it wasn't
there all of these shows were
Progressive because they were all from
people who were outcasts in life who
those are the ones who want to push for
a better more inclusive world not the
centrists they like it as it
is uh I'm going to hop off my Soap Box
my space box you're allow it's your
birthday you're allowed to say these
things uh it is eight minutes from 9
oock here on the West Coast which means
it is eight minutes from Midnight on the
east coast and midnight on the East
Coast brings us to the 29th which is
Mark's birthday indeed so eight more
minutes eight more minutes come on JC we
can't get a clock going in
that b man where's our countdown clock
that we just decided we
needed I'll work on it I'll work on it
I'm gonna try to get it up not necessary
but yes seven minutes now Mark will be
minutes a 52 years young man I will be
like a reboot of the DC Universe I'll be
the new 52 oh my God that's right look
at you hopefully you'll be more
successful they replaced that new 52
with another universe and then replaced
it again I think yeah it's like new 52
didn't work now you die just turn
welcome to the new 53 no new 54
uhuh um six minutes dougy fresh you're
on that's
right all right you got news we got some
news baby let's hear about that news
um Viva the boys Mexico did you see the
news there's going to be a boys spin-off
called boys Mexico
was it the two kids from
um E2 Mama Toman Diego Luna and GA
Garcia beral are set to Executive
produce and are considering taking on
acting roles um though neither would be
major according to to deadline um it's
coming from Blue Beetle writer Gareth
dunet alcoser I'll pretend that's how
it's pronounced um according to to
deadline a search is currently underway
for a co- show runner to join uh D aler
who's now working on the script the team
behind the boys Mexico which will be
shot in the Latin American country is
currently working on budgets for the new
series and they have yet to begin
casting um there is not much to be said
plot-wise about what it is or who it's
who it's from besides them and Eric kryy
is of course overseeing it all uh Seth
Rogan and Evan Goldberg's Point gray is
producing um but yeah the boys continues
to be the Well from which U much of
Amazon Prime success Springs Amazon's
like we got
one they Annie poted it there's a clock
up man check it out oh damn there it is
we're less than five minutes till Mark
turns 52 kids and you're gonna watch
happen you're G you will believe a man
can
age right in front of your eyes I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be the old dude from
Last Crusade when the clock
turns like all the the white hair will
come streaming out of my eyes
he chose poorly um take us into the
news uh next news item beyond the boys
Mexico which hey I'm I'm here for I
understand the the pull of it and
anytime you can widen the scope of a of
an IP give it a go guys give it a
go yeah um we had talked at
Great length I think uh I the last
episode or the episode before it about
the problems facing Marvel Visa
Kang um whether or not you completely
move on from Kang and jump straight to
to the Fantastic Four whether or not the
Kang Dynasty is about the Jonathan major
version of Kang or another variant who
we haven't seen yet so you're
recasting maybe um gooo and baa raw's
Ren Slayer is actually a Kang variant
and she becomes your villain which I'm
particularly fond of because I think
she's awesome um or maybe that movie
just goes away entirely
but as of yesterday U Michael Waldren um
who uh is currently working on Avengers
Secret Wars has now been tapped to write
the prequel to that uh the Kang Dynasty
so the next two Avenger movies will be
written by the same guy um he was also
the person who wrote Doctor Strange in
the the Multiverse of Madness as well as
the showrunner of Loki season 1 um so
maybe this movie is not dead after all
um given that they just hired a person
to hop aboard and write it um they the
idea of skipping the Kang Dynasty and
going right into Secret Wars man yeah
you know or it's entirely possible they
change the name of the movie or they
already have and just haven't told us
yet um or yeah they're just sticking
with Kang and Kang is going to be the
guy and they will do a lot of heavy
lifting to make us fear the coming of
the Kang Dynasty which I don't think an
audience does yet um stop trying stop
trying to make Kang
happened not happening yet he's
happening he's he's happening he ain't
going nowhere he was uh the the um did
we talk about did you finally see the
end of Loki yeah I did yes yeah yeah um
felt like w Kang up in the end of that
though where they were like well we'll
keep our eye on that guy but not in the
way of like you know he's coming back
right
like yeah it was never like Thanos is
coming it was more like there's a Thanos
and he's currently totally happy and
content whatever plan he's
on it is one minute and
576 55 seconds less than two minutes
till Mark hits 52
Mark what can you tell these fine folks
at home about being half a century old
plus two
years my uh my grandfather would ask me
every birthday that I had like so how
does it feel and granted he was born in
the year 1900 and so would be asking me
these questions when I was turning like
15 and like you don't give a about
when you're turning 15 it's like I
don't know Grandad feels like I felt
yesterday like everything is great my
body is a temple I can do I can run and
jump and bend and pick up whatever I
want and lift things and the world is my
oyster it's going to open for me like a
magnificent vagina ch um now at 52 yes
it's uh it's a little bit different it's
a little bit you know uh you've learned
some you've done some you know
it the the the lesson that I have
learned in my dotage is that is less the
things you get to do and more the people
you get to do them with um it uh it is
never the places it's always the
faces God damn it
soon there it
[Music]
is that
guy um kids less than 30 seconds 25
seconds till Mark takes the big
jump till my uh my palm begins to Blink
and I will be called back to the
motherboard he's going to regenerate
he's gonna face change it's going to be
David Tennant here it is seven seconds
and four three two one literally happy
New
Year yeah it's we did it the 52nd of
such I am 52 in the Bronx that's all
I'll say watch your
hip look at that chat's alive with happy
birthday oh they love their Mar yalls
are the
sweetest um they can't get enough look
at them oh from all around the globe
from the UK there's one dude in China
from China from uh from all over the
globe kids
Fel graas all right back to the news old
man back to the news um Dave filon has
been named new Chief creative officer at
Lucasville whose job did he take did he
take's job he did not take anybody's job
it seems to be a a uh a newly created
position uh just for him uh according to
filon and Vanity Fair which broke the
news in the past and a lot of projects
would be brought into it I would see it
after it had already been developed to
good ways um now he'll be involved in
the early development on Star Wars
projects working with Kathy Kennedy as
the head of Lucas film and head of
development Carrie Beck oh that's uh
Carrie I mean she's been working on all
the Star Wars things
for for a while now and stuff she works
at Lucas film and she has her own you
know career and stuff but she is
also married to a friend of mine Brian
Lynch oh look at that yeah every time
one of them shows I'm like I know her
like she her Brian Lynch their first
date was here at this house and stuff
they've been married they got a kid
Henry and whatnot that's awesome works
on all those Star Wars shows and whatnot
and he writes the Minions movies he does
he's a he's a a big time animation
writer he is man he Talent
prolific as hell man put you to shame in
terms of like making you feel like
you're a writer because it's like he
writes like 10 scripts before breakfast
and and each one of them are like
fully legit you could shoot him they're
brilliant he's he's a very
talented
individual um it was announced back in
April at Star Wars celebration that day
filon is developing a liveaction feature
to direct one that is said to tie
together the time period between Return
of the Jedi and force awakens and will
presumably feature some of the
characters from both the Clone Wars and
Ahsoka um and the Mandalorian for that
matter oh wow does it look just like me
it's a it's a stunning
likeness me as a Mr Potato Head
kids been around 30 years I entered the
I've entered the culture I'm a poptater
man look at that you can take my face
off and
um according filon I am not telling
people what to do but I do feel I'm
trying to help them tell the best story
that they do want to tell I need to be
help across the Galaxy here like a part
of a Jedi
Council um very on brand very on brand
all of which I think is to say that if
you like the current iteration of Star
Wars on TV um as sort of I do as you
know sort of Guided by Dave filon in his
previous role as you know mentor and
Keeper of the for and and the the sage
in the Wes of Lucas then you'll get more
of that um if you are not um thrilled
with some of the later iterations of
Star Wars on TV you'll get more of that
um so hey like Bully for you or hey
we'll we'll survive it it's just a dude
who got a new job and hopefully we'll
make Star Wars better I gotta tell you
you know I think they should maybe take
a page out of the forthcoming Marvel
book and you know I mean I guess they're
now just committed to like Star Wars as
a TV show as opposed to a theatrical
cinematic experience I mean I know he's
talking about making a movie but maybe
maybe you know few less shows maybe a
few more movies I I mean they still have
the the upcoming the forthcoming Ray
movie that was announced uh a while back
that they're returning to that character
is she starts a new Jedi Order
post rise of Skywalker and whatever
version of of the the filon movie
whatever that's going to be um but yeah
I mean Star Wars and we're GNA get
another season of Andor like the trailer
leaked for season two of Andor on I saw
on on X the other day and
uh all you do have to do say Star Wars
three times B
show uh I know I'm doing after the
show um I'm G to go watch Andor and then
I need to you
chicken did
uh uh did you guys see the news maybe
I'm jumping the gun but uh Pedro pescal
said I think he's done with
Mandalorian but him saying I'm done
being the physical actor but I'll do the
voice because it's the easiest job in in
the world I don't think he's doing going
to do the voice anymore either I thought
I saw a news
story Star Wars oh well maybe it's maybe
it's one of those fake news sites that I
saw I mean what an easy gig walk away
from you don't even have to be the guy
anymore like is John Wayne's grandson in
the suit right yeah brand although it
looks like now I'm looking at it it
looks like it's uh one of those fake
news sites that I saw never
[Music]
mind
I mean I did see that there was all of
this like there was the a news bit or a
rumor that broke that he's being eyed to
play uh Reed Richards in Fantastic 4
which nobody has confirmed yet um Marvel
hasn't confirmed Disney hasn't confirmed
he hasn't said anything about it but one
of the you know paragraph four of that
potentially fake news story was like
pending his ability to negotiate his
schedule as like the lead of Last of Us
season 2 and and the Mandalorian does he
actually have time to be Reed Richards
for the foreseeable future and whatever
two or three other things he's got lined
up that he's committed to um but yeah I
mean of them all the Mando is the
lightest lift because it's like I'm
gonna get on the phone and dial in my
dialogue and uh I'll be on set I'll go
to Manhattan Beach for a week and shoot
what I need to shoot for the season when
I take the mask off I mean is he even
GNA do that or does he just like use
that James Earl Jones AI thing for me
just send me one of those new sag checks
yeah like it's also not a big acting
challenge to just say uh Hey where's the
kid
yeah um by Creed I gotta bathe in the
waters of L minetonka
yeah I know what that um the
uh the Fantastic forecasting Rumor Mill
has been on fire lately um they've been
saying Pedro pescal for Mr Fantastic was
a Vanessa Kirby
for for Sue storm uh but we were just
talking about the bear before and the
guy who plays Richie they're talking
about him
for um the thing Ean Ean Moss backrack I
think his name is
um I mean I buy it that dude's great I
love them in the
bear uh Joshua mundall mundall is asking
in chat Smokin rescheduled for January
20th maybe possibly Sundance clerk
celebration um yeah we've had to
reschedule a bunch of things that we
were supposed to be doing at mod Castle
in December because of what happened
with Jen um but most of them are getting
rescheduled
including uh SM auction which is like
just an auction live auction um Batman
Returns we're going to be showing um
that had to be moved from December um
and uh what was the other
thing um Zach and muie screening that
got moved and um oh I think in January
we're gonna be doing the clerks open and
all night marathon where you watch
clerks Clerks 2 and clerks 3 in your
pajamas you stay all night we start at
midnight or 11:58 so we can get in under
the midnight ordinance that Atlantic
Islands has and then watch all three
movies and um it's going to be around
you know the 30th anniversary of us
going to Sundance so that's going to be
cool tickets for those will be
going up in the next few weeks it's mod
Castle
cinemas.com back to you mark with the
news uh Timothy olifant the Great and
Powerful Timothy olant has been
cast all the Fantastic it's been cast in
Noah Holly's alien TV show
um so that Noah Holly is the guy that is
does Fargo indeed and so that alien
thing is happening I don't think it's
happening I think it's currently in
production um and I think it might have
even been shooting during the strike
because it's it's shooting overseas I
think a lot of the actors are like actor
Equity instead of sag so it's all a
little muddy and fuzzy but um but yeah
it's it's back up and running in
Thailand I think
think um yeah yeah yeah according to
this news bit from variety production on
the show began in Thailand on July 19th
four days after the start of the active
strike without any sag members it
continued for more than a month with
cast who were affiliated with with the
British Equity Trade
union um let's see apparently this show
uh is a prequel to alien I think um
details about alin's character are not
being dis closed um but according to the
rumor mill I.E deadline he's playing
kersch a synth who acts as a mentor and
a trainer for a character who's a hybrid
a metahuman who has the brain and
consciousness of a child but the body of
an
adult I just want somebody to work for
wh and utani if they don't do that
then it's not my alien amen amen um so
weird man that
like I you know on one hand I'm a fan so
I'm like oh my God give me an aliens TV
show but on the other hand if everything
becomes a TV show
like how do you put that Genie back in
the bottle you know if you're giving him
aliens on TV will they ever go back into
a theater to see aliens um well there's
also an alien feature that's coming down
the pike that's been directed by fed
Alvarez it's already done it's already
done I think Ridley Scott has has seen
it and has given his Blessing and it
takes place between alien and
Aliens so it's that's an concept when's
that um I I mean next year at some point
I don't think they have a release date
for it yet but if I had to guess I'd say
like spring of
24 um but yeah post Nostromo
prako um I don't think Ripley is
involved in it because she would have
been um still in suspended animation but
I think that's the one where you get
aliens in
it I think that you know this no Holly
show may or may not have any xenop
forbins
Xenomorphs um so I don't know I don't
know oh Holly also do um the show that
um cers is always trying to get me to
watch Legion he
did oh Jamie cers I know it's been a
minute since we've seen I know we we got
close if not for a curse my metal body
it wasn't fast enough old man
back it's been buckling under the weight
of the world um the spinal tap sequel 40
years
later uh Rob Riner director writer and
star of This Is Spinal uh has spoken on
a podcast most recently saying we're
making a sequel we're going to start
shooting at the end of February and
everybody is back and he also teased
that Paul McCartney Elton John G Brooks
and a few other surprises would be
making cameos in the in the film um and
it's most likely that he's going to
return as Marty degie a filmmaker who is
chronicling the lives of the band during
whatever leg of whatever tour they're on
now and when there you're saying they're
going into production soon
February we're GNA start shooting in the
end of February I'm all for it
like you know I I I I love spinal tap I
love Christopher Guest I watch him do
anything I think those three guys
together are always good remember when
they did A Mighty Wind and they played
full um I wonder if FR drer will be
back
wow um what the world how's the world
reacting to is the internet up in arms
like or are they welcoming it
um I so far I have not seen a ton of
Buzz about it um it might it might be
one of those things that is a cult film
to a certain generation and that
generation is no longer film Twitter
yeah you know and so like film Twitter
doesn't quite seem to care as much as
say we do because it was this seminal
film that you like passed around vhs's
of in high school like you got to
see this this is crazy he's got
an armadillo in his trousers but it's
really just a cucumber wrapped
in tin
foil um that's good it's a
good yeah it comes and
goes sometimes it's great and sometimes
it's shitty poisonous plants 15 in chat
said Noah Holly literally confirms
Xenomorphs are in the show when it was
announced two years ago outstanding oh I
watched uh mean Dave said either of you
guys watched the Albert Brooks doc I did
have you watched it as did I oh I love
also watched the I think I don't know if
I talked about this last episode but did
you watch the Sylvester Stallone doc did
we talk about
I I think I did I mentioned
it think you did I watch it did we hit
it last week yeah we hit Sly at the end
of last show loved it man but in
any event what was the one I mentioned
right before that Alber Albert Brooks
Albert Brooks fantastic documentary yeah
um even if like it's crazy how much I
forgot like oh my God that's right he is
a taxi
driver like yeah yeah the bit that that
sort of a the story of his father's
death
blew me the away like I didn't I
mean I'm not an Albert Brooks scholar
there's quite a bit about him that I
didn't know and so getting to revisit a
lot of those early bits that I just like
I came to him with with with um
Defending Your Life and Finding Nemo and
like would sort of see him do like
little bits and pieces but all of that
early 70s all of the Like Tonight
Show stuff was like I would never
rehearse any of it like I'd come up with
an idea I'd think about it backst agage
and then Johnny would say well here's
Albert Brooks and I'd come out and I'd
do a thing um I didn't I never had like
a hot five I never all of it was sort of
extemporaneous and improv and ballsy um
but yeah it was that and the Satur live
stuff when he's like yeah Lauren
Michaels asked me to host the whole the
show in perpetuity wanted me to be the
permanent host and I'm like maybe Albert
Brooks and the not ready for Prime Time
Players but he was the one that was like
you should have rotating hosts yeah you
should have a guess those every week no
not a bad idea and but I will give you
filmed bits you know six of them in the
first season and that would become a
thing that they did for the next 45
years of just we're gonna we're going to
do the live stuff and then we're going
to cut the that we shot beforehand
and if not for Albert Brooks neither of
those would have been parts of the the
sort of language of SNL me and Dave says
watch the Bob Einstein doc too if you
haven't because Bob Einstein was super
Dave
Osborne was Albert Brooks's brother
because Albert Brooks's last name is
really Einstein his name Einstein so
cute story
documentary um that was definitely worth
watching though yeah check out that
Albert Brooks documentary on Max I think
it's on yeah like I went I went I spent
a little bit of time in a like celebrity
documentary
hole um which is very easy to to to sink
into because it's all the Nostalgia it's
just all of the that you kind of
remember but then the stories behind it
that you never knew like I started
watching the Robbie Williams documentary
on Netflix and like I was never a big
Robbie Williams fan but like the Odyssey
of like former boy band gone solo
becoming super famous in the UK and then
crashing and burning like that is
always kind of fascinating and like oh I
remember that I remember that song oh
here's when he dated you know
Baby Spice like apparently everybody in
Britain had to go with a Spice Girl if
you were famous enough you could date a
Spice Girl for a little bit um that
stuff is always fascinating to
me um Maggie Oran in chat keeps asking
did I like meeting the Mayhem cast cast
of the Electric Mayhem absolutely um it
was working with Muppets even for like
the brief time I did was absolutely
magical it's crazy how God sticking a
hand into a cloth thing brings
it to life to the point where not even
talking to the person operating them up
and you're just talking to the Muppet
looking into its eyes uh but they
announced that they're not moving
forward with another season I didn't
even know that was an option um felt
like a one-off to me but um yeah so
they're not moving forward with another
Dr teeth in the Electric Mayhem season
but Adam Goldberg who is you know the
force one of the major forces behind
that Siri said hey man but I'm I'm not
leaving them mu it's alone he didn't say
that must sck my hand up some asses yeah
he's like I ain't done Jam my hand up a
muppet ass so he'll be uh um working on
new Muppet stuff going forward it's
awesome yeah there should always be
Muppets on the air um next I'm gonna
watch somebody says Eddie Murphy as well
there's not an Eddie Murphy Doc is there
I don't believe so no I watch out
he's got a movie like Christmas movie I
look forward to yeah did you see that I
I believe it's Eddie Murphy's son is
dating Martin Lawrence's daughter did
you see that he read that yeah and he
was talking about like hanging out with
them on Thanksgiving can you imagine
that
Thanksgiving like the Lawrence Hercules
Hercules Hercules Murphy how hold on
Thanksgiving um you wouldn't your face
would hurt from it would be like when
the Joker gives somebody Joker venom
they have a Rus
grin just be laughing the whole time
yeah or it would be like listen are
there any cameras here no is anybody
paying us no then you don't get any
funny just sit there and eat
your turkey can't
imagine like competitive
too like I remember being at a photo
shoot when I was at the Hollywood
Reporter and we were doing a photo shoot
with with Key and Peele with with Keegan
Michael Key and Jordan Peele and this
was when their show was still on the air
like it was like season two of keyan
Peele and there was a big like breakouts
or or whatever the we were calling
it and so we had this like they were
dressed in like white suits and we're
were going to do a thing it's funny and
there's a table full of props for them
to like be funny with and like big
rubber hammer and a mallet and wrenches
and like the little TNT Acme bomb
and watching them stand at the table and
and dissect what was on it and decide
what would be the funniest was like
surgeons talking about how they're going
to attack a gallbladder I was
like well you could pick up the rber
chicken and then I'll pick up the giant
scissors but then if you pick up the
pingpong and I have like a bunch of
balls in my mouth like it was it was
deadly serious about comedy that like
they were not like being funny it was
we're at work we'll be funny when it's
time to be funny when the cameras are
rolling you get the funny but
otherwise it's you and me just in the
lab uh touching back on Eddie
Murphy did you see the picture of him as
Axel Foley from
bever I mean I got crazy unnecessarily
excited by it's essentially just Eddie
Murphy but like I was like oh my God
it's happening it's happening I know
it's like I've seen Beverly Hills cops
two and three like I should not be
excited for four yet I am am somebody
wrote an article online I don't know
which website it was but they were like
could you know could Beverly Hills Cop 4
be the Top Gun of
Comedy wow and I was like that's not a
bad stretch I'm sure somebody in chat
will tell me who wrote that article I
mean there was the BR Hills cop TV show
that never went the pilot of which he
was in um but in AAR like I don't know
how that doesn't get made unless it's an
awful pilot which it very well may have
but I'm still here man Lou Louis
Rodriguez or Louis Rodriguez said uh the
boy who lived doc on Max was really
moving there's a documentary that uh
Harry Potter Daniel Radcliffe Radcliffe
did about what his stunt double who was
injured during the movie yeah I think
during one of the Deathly Hollows like
suffered an accident like took a bad
fall and I think broke his back and and
so he made a document about this guy
like what do you do after that like what
happens you know when you're when the
thing you thought you were going to do
for the rest of his life is not in the
cards anymore haven't seen it like I'm
very curious about it
but that sounds like a terribly tragic
slash uplifting optimistic
story The Writers uh strike is over and
sag said hey we're we we're come to you
know terms as well but did sag
do their vote and sign their thing yet
or no um the last day of ratifying for
them is December 5th I believe um so
they are not they are not completely
settled um with the studios and there
are as there always are um there's
there's a there's a healthy I'm hoping a
minority of descent with what the deal
contains there's a lot of sort of vote
no and vote Yes and people are just not
with the deal um and are encouraging
people not to ratify it and to go back
to the the negotiating table with the
studios I don't know if they're going to
call another strike or not um I don't
know if it's going to pass or not I
don't think anybody has a has a clue as
to what's going to happen but a town
that was just about to go back to work
is currently a little bit on pins and
needles about like so are we done are we
not done thought we were done
yeah so can an actor act yet or no um
they can this the strike has been called
off actors can go back to work but
they're currently going back to work
under the old contract because the new
one has yet to be
ratified um but we'll see what happens
you know I mean a lot of movies and TV
shows are back up and running
which you know they may not call another
strike because you know I don't know
what their support would be for another
strike I don't know if the their guilds
would be out in support of another
strike like I don't think the writers
are going to go back on the picket line
with them I don't know if if the if s if
the animation guilds or AI or the
teamsters or anything I don't know this
is a Brave New World of Union
negotiations
but I don't know and I don't know the
entirety of why people are unhappy with
it Beyond potentially um I think the AI
protections are not stiff enough for
some folks um but we haven't seen at
least I haven't as not a member of sag
is not seen the full deal yet I don't
know what's in the new contract so I
don't know exactly what people are
unhappy about but you know knock on wood
that people come to a resolution of
their differences I believe in
labor says The Working Man right there
kids you're first hot take Mark
believes um I am just uh checking text
from the patient upstairs if you will
how is she feeling does she need some
soup she's good no she's good she's like
you're still doing your show and I was
like it's not my show it's all of
them world
show I do this for the people yeah
really come on man um all right what
else we got um finally the last story of
the news is hard to call it a sad one I
always have a difficult time um um when
we talk about a person of an advanced
age who's passed away but had lived a
life full of wonder and joy and brought
wonder and joy to people but Marty Croft
producer of uh hit shows like HR Puffin
stuff The Brady Bunch hour banana splitz
and Land of the Lost has died at the age
of
86 86 that's how old he he got 86 yeah
what an inventive creative person this
was him and was his brother or cousin
his brother his older brother s the
brother Sid Sid and Marty Croft were you
know without them my childhood would
have been a lot less interesting
colorful um these cats just produced
like crazy inventive children's
programming um that you know in an era
of cartoons lots of
cartoons they held up like a mirror to
the audience like you could see yourself
hanging out with Sigman the sea
monster and stuff um just like Johnny
and Scott um or you know you could find
yourself blowing a Magic
Flute yeah you could you could like
witchie poo and like
Thanksgiving in my house we're blowing
this Magic Flute again out said Marty
coft man like one of my lamest jokes in
Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back was
Marshall will and Holly and that's
Marshall will and Holly on a routine EXP
the greatest earthquake ever known Land
of the Lost kids far out Space Nuts the
losto
Lidsville of course HR puffing stuff
where you go when things get rough which
is like exactly as filthy as I meant
it um just crazy amount
of
shows yeah and Marie the Brady brunch
hour pink lady and Jeff Barbara Mandrell
and The Mandrell Sisters God I used to
watch that show all the time too I
forgot time the nighttime variety shows
as well yeah prior Place DC
Folly prior plays that was a show that
got a lot of Awards and stuff
yeah like peewee's Playhouse kind of
thing um yeah I mean in 2003 they
awarded the lifetime career Award of the
Saturn award
um in 2018 Marty and his brother
received a lifetime achievement Emmy
Award from the National Academy of TV
Arts and Sciences and in 2020 they
received a star on the Walk of Fame in
celebration of their golden
anniversary um
man what a what a wonderful time it was
to grow up yeah you know and like the
70s were a crazy time in television
um we like what are we going to do we're
going to make a costume in the
back of this Factory we're going to put
a dune in it and we're going to shoot a
100 episodes of children's TV what's he
gonna be a sea monster all right
cool let's roll let's do it like
you can't make TV like that anymore um
it it costs too much you know there's
too many you know shareholder approvals
and 98 levels of ratification and all
that stuff but these two were just like
it do it they're the bugaloos what
are the boogaloos I don't know nobody
knows let go as a kid you felt like
um you know oh my God these shows are
amazing as an adult you're like wow a
lot of these shows seem like they were
like smoke them if you got him just big
hats it's all it is
big he's a mad man with an evil mind he
shrinks right in the
name listen one level it's a kid show
there can't be multiple levels Happening
Here his name is Sigman he's a sea
monster what does he do he's a sea
monster you guys yeah and they're
friends and they're friends don't
overthink it um Good Times man oh
somebody put gangster Jedi pointed out
in chat Bigfoot and Wild Boy remember
that Bigfoot Wild Boy I love that show I
think they did did they do no were they
Bigfoot wble yeah that's not L shimer
right like the Isis and Shazam that was
that was not yeah Sid Marty Croft that
was like shim the circle logo that was
on the the shinard wig Corporation
remember like uh Fat Albert had that
circle logo those two names Lou
shimer and somebody else I I believe
they were involved with the Masters of
the Universe f
remember um well thank you Mr
Croft remember the Croft
Superstars yeah fool and the
Kongs um see yeah s Marty Croft
Bigfoot and Wild Boy
wow um there it is
big part of our this is
brother's still around or no his brother
is said is still
alive um survived by his brother and
like there's another brother Harry and
then a bunch of kids and a couple of
grandkids um yeah that is that is a
legacy you know you've affected a series
of childhoods for the
better not a bad way to go Kabuki kid in
chat says loved how puffing stuff had a
dead arm because the guy in the suit had
to move the mouth also the way that big
bird works
M there's so many people in a bird yeah
it's just got his one of the arms just
hangs there he's like a Bob Dole with
the one arm and but the other hand
goes a
bum remember he used to have the pen in
that
hand dad happened to my dad after a
stroke as well he was we'd call him Big
Bird because one of arm was just like
there like a bob do good old
dad but that is the the news my friend
there it is kidss there's the
news y'all wanted it got it oh did did
you guys see the TAA
news what um he said the one where he
said he did Thor Ragnarok because he was
broke and needed the money yeah yeah and
and then went on to say like Thor's the
stupid most people porn I was broke and
I need the money yeah he's like I just
had my second kid I figured this would
be a good way to feed them babies
I think was the quote and then he's like
he's like Thor is the worst character
they only hired me because they were out
of other people I that
well uh it reminds me of a there's a pet
and ell bit where he talks about like
Nickelback and and being a young fan of
music and it's like yeah you guys are
just in it for the money and the
it's like that's why everybody does
everything for money and like how
was that selling out
true true does anybody do anything for
dick uh I'm not sure I don't but you
under my presidency you would if you
wanted a
turkey you a gobble that knob
right there I mean without a sponsor I
remember before son Bob was
President we didn't have to suck off
these
turke this is raw what a raw
deal yeah just gobble gobble baby gobble
gobble get back down there got B
man I was just going to say without a
sponsor tonight we're doing the show for
free that's very true Point man trer
words were never spoken so take that ta
wititi would you do a 2our and 15 Minute
Podcast for free and Counting I don't
think so we're up to yeah it's going to
be a short show tonight because there's
no
sponsor we always spend so much time on
the sponsor uh h o d g e y Sy y l81
says bring back Comic Book Men bring
Comic Book Men back oh I would love to I
don't have any say in that that was AMC
was like you
could you could off now no they
were very nice they were like we did
Seven Seasons That's it ironically
enough like every season I was like
there's no way they renew this
show and they kept renewing it and I was
always shocked and then I had that heart
attack and I was like well we know
they're renewing the show this year
because there's no way they would ever
cancel it now that I've had a heart
attack one month
later they're like you all right you
back from that heart attack are you
sitting down we're canceling your
J I was never mad or anything I
was always like I can't believe we got
as many seasons seven season I wish they
would put it out on Blu-ray though um
you know I'm a physical media guy like
I'm sure they actually canceled the show
like a month before they told you and
they were just waiting until you were on
the menend enough like we can't tell him
now like we canceled it the day he had
the heart attack he just had a heart
attack um all right what do we
uh what do we got we got questions there
JC yeah we got some questions um the 757
hustle show wanted to know wait we're
just diving into these qu Jesus you want
to go in
yeah we're we're getting into the
questions kids now the Q&A part begins
three questions then we get the out
of here they better all be birthday
oriented
considering special birthday Edition Mr
Mark Bernard if you've just tuned in
late has turned 52 years old today kids
while the show was happening right on
the on the East Coast technically my
birthday is the 29th but it is the 29th
in uh in New York City and in the UK and
all those other places that aren't Los
Angeles M and I'm a little pissed that
nobody from the future calls me and
warns me about like hey you know
what we saw the news over here it's
going to be up in three hours
yeah really where's the you should
leave um what do we got what do we got
all right uh we don't have any birthday
questions um one person asked which I
guess we could answer but I didn't think
it was very appropriate Q&A they were
like uh what do you like best about Mark
I was like well I could answer that and
Kevin probably answer that but if Mark
answers that it's a
trap
so uh that's as close as we got to a
birthday question I like my wrists I've
got good
wrists never let me down he's right his
wrists are great and they've never let
me down either yeah been exercising them
since I was
13 hold
fast
knuckles all right uh 757 hustle show um
from any franchise
who would pair up with the doctor to
ride around in the Tardis so who would
we pair up with the doctor to ride
around in the
Tardis H from outside a different
franchise uh Darth
Vader Time Lord and a Sith
Lord
call it the Lords of flat
Bush oi listen would you stop hacking
everybody who opens the
door he he the title refers to
the fact that he uses lightsaber to trim
somebody's
Bush trim Lords of flat Lords of flat
Bush it's all about it's all about
excellent great um no who would I pair
up with Doctor
Who Um
I'd create my own character Dr
what I'm not getting out doct what doct
you yeah it man why aren't
they why aren't they like marketing this
as the the query Universe right
like they got a doctor who you know how
like uh what's his name was like
hey man there's all these lanterns now
Jeff Johns like there's a thousand
Lantern a Yellow Lantern there a
Red Lantern why can't they have a
doctor who a doctor what a doctor where
a doctor when and a doctor why the five
doctors nice get five different shows
man like
this this is what's gonna happen
in the Disney era isn't it we're gonna
get yeah and they've all got
different color uh magic
[Laughter]
screwdrivers um Russell Davies call us
me and Mark got ideas we got it then
we're gonna do lawyer who and like pilot
who and uh and and and Chief Inspector
who guess
who you cross it over with Dr Seuss like
Doctor Who and Whoville it's uh do guess
who is basically um we give you little
portions of their faces you got to
figure out which characters are which
and classic children's game Guess
Who indeed um all right wait did we did
you answer the question Darth 24 912
just said Kevin just came up with a new
doctor show it's true he did telling you
man the the universe could literally be
Doctor Who yes we've had him for 60
years but it's time to introduce Dr why
Dr what Dr when Dr which Dr
how Dr how is the irritating one he's
like a doubting Thomas yeah you know
Council of doctors like we're all in
agreement and he's like why they like
that's Dr why like Doctor Who's the one
who wants to do and everybody else
is like what stop it Dr what but Dr why
is Dr why is a
toddler we you got to go to the bathroom
before we go to dinner why why why like
oh I can't stand there a young doctor
like that Doogie
Hower the DXs are coming we've got to
stop them why because they're going to
take over the Galaxy why they they find
out like hey man we thought all the time
Lords died but guess what four
more of them were in like a pocket
Universe in The Phantom Zone yes here's
your siblings Dr what Dr why Dr
when Dr which Dr
where yeah I think it regenerated in his
pants telling you man that and then
there's a then you build toward
a Doctor Who
what are those is there a name for those
words in the English language who what
when where why um I think they're
probably are they're like journalistic
words it's like the whatever the five
W's or some like that that's right
position
war and then it would put them you
collect the five W's put them on a glove
and then doctor you know all the doctors
only one could live right so
then you build out all these doctors and
then collapse it all into the one doctor
whoop and everyone's happy again yeah
except for the one there's the one that
didn't get collapsed who then hates the
other
doctors yeah I like it I like it um who
would I put in the Tardis with Doctor
Who uh Axel
Foley suddenly see hey it's always fun
when you have a black person on a time
travel show and they're like not getting
out of the why we're in
1950s Alabama this is not a good place
for me to be time travel is not as cool
for me as it is for you but also like
can solve in with Ingenuity and
humor did you just put a banana in the
ot's tail pipe yeah I did you're
not gonna fall for the banana and the
Tardis trick
again um right Raymond Rogers in chat uh
Raymond Rogers in chat says they're
called
interrogatives ooh interrogative oper
operative that's pretty sweet man the
inter the Council of interrogatives
Doctor Who Dr when Dr why Dr which Dr
what Dr where yeah they asked all the
big questions in the
universe dude like he thought it began
and ended with
who check out all the other
interrogatives oh my God
stop talking stop talking no
look what you did get with somebody over
there yeah dear BBC I got an
idea they're like come on you know how
many times we've all discussed Dr where
Dr why
do yeah but see they call Doctor Who on
the mat for up the universe he's
the Rogue doctor everybody else is
playing by the rules they've asked
questions doctor who feels like he's got
too many answers and that's the problem
and each one the Tardis is a different
color like blue yellow green red yeah
one of them is a toilet that's bigger on
the inside the other one's a phone booth
the other one's a call box the other
one's like a changing closet in the
department store see now we're selling
action
figures
yeah's a shower
stall um all right I like it I uh my
pitch I was going to say Dr doitt
because the Tardis is bigger on the
inside and you could do like a a second
Noah's Arc movie where he's like we got
to get all these animals somewhere Dr
dittle and you know Doctor Who shows up
and he's like I know the place and they
all go into the Tardis um but I
think the better option is a Bill and
Ted
nice nice excellent
PLL Top
Notch uh okay question number two Adam
Dalton uh says thank you all for being
positive even when you are critical of
the things we love how would you
recommend others do the same without
falling into the YouTube Fanning the
flame death trap
meaning uh how when we hate something
how do we we don't like it without being
negative and getting lots of
clicks wait what so how do we not go
negative how do we not go negative last
last show we talked about how we should
just all go negative and get all the
clicks oh right how how how do we uh
Express disappointment in a thing but
still keep the show positive what tips
do we have to other creators out there I
just from for me my tip I just don't
talk about the I don't like it's
that's simple so if I see a thing and
I'm like underwhelmed by it or I didn't
like it you just I just don't talk about
it um I got time for the things I like
and if I didn't like it I you know you
rarely will you ever find out I didn't
like a thing but um if I spend a little
time talking about like oh it wasn't
what I hoped or whatever you know
I'm always the first to be like look
they're better directors than me and I
could never make anything as good as
this but
uh you know it's sometimes if you can't
say something nice don't say anything at
all um there's enough folks out there
expressing every single thought out loud
about every
single thing um and that's what
the internet's for that's what social
media is for but you know I I I just
don't talk about this stuff I don't like
why give it err
um and why like you know
I know how hard it is to make a
thing even if I don't go for it
it's like I'm not going to belittle its
existence which you know was somebody's
vision and this entire crew got
together and made his thing happen and
you know the fact that it ran the
gauntlet to find financing and stuff
like you know I I just just because it's
not my thing don't mean I'm going to
spend any time in its mouth I
know there's an entire
economy on the internet and specifically
on YouTube that's about like I hate it
don't you hate it aren't you mad
and I'm just you know maybe it's easy to
say I'm not mad because kind of
worked out for me um in life and stuff
but I get frustrations but I just don't
like like God it's it would seem like it
would get so tiring being that
angry and disappointed and like just
focus on the that makes you happy
and focus on the you do like and if
you don't like
something consider you know does the
world need to know you don't like it you
know I know people like I paid my money
I get to say what I want sure absolutely
but the question is how do we not go
negative and uh you know maybe it's just
not called for not everybody needs to
know every single thought they
have says the guy who's like did
comicbook.com write about me this
week is that's the only way I know I'm
still relevant or not that's that's me
from that's how I do it I just don't
generally talk about there's a time
early in my career where I let
you know all the I didn't like and
I I don't like that like I look back at
those moments where I'm like what a
little dick young Kevin Smith
was in the mouth of stuff that
like now old Kevin Smith knows how
hard it was to make those things
and just because they weren't my cup of
tea don't mean I got to jump online and
be like e they ruined everything
like there's plenty of good things to
talk about focus on
that um yeah I mean I I one of my jobs
my many jobs before I made TV was I was
a Critic I was a Critic for
Entertainment Weekly I would I would
have to write reviews of things usually
movies and they were usually 100 words
long and like I found that the Venoms
slips easier than the praise it is
incredibly easy and it's it's a dopamine
hit to come up with a 200w slam of a
thing and it's simple to do um you know
it's easier to destroy than it is to
create and the challenge was always
defending a thing that you loved more
than it was slamming a thing that you
hated because hate is just it's shitty
it's awful here's the two ways that it's
awful but telling somebody that you like
a thing becomes a bit of you know
evangelism it becomes advocacy um and
that is both harder and more rewarding
when you can say that you love a thing
and and exhort other people to love it
as well um and I I think when I started
professionally writing TV one of the
first things I learned about being in a
writer's room was don't pitch like
if you've got a problem with something
that the room is coming up with it's
super easy to say oh that doesn't
work oh that's awful oh that's
whatever don't say anything unless you
can pitch a solution to that you can
pitch an ALT you can pitch a a different
way of getting at the same problem it's
your thing um and so that that is how I
come to things that that I'm not as
satisfied with as I could be is that
it's easy to say oh that was awful I
hate it it's garbage but instead you're
like well okay I I didn't like it here's
why and if I had to pitch a solution for
the reasons why I didn't like it here's
how
you know it's how I learned to write
which is is sort of reverse engineering
things and figuring out what worked or
didn't work and how do you replicate it
and that's that is my expression of
distaste and hopefully it never comes
across as Venom or hatred or um you know
just just anger that it comes across as
like let's use this as a learning tool
it's an opportunity for us to figure out
how stories work and not every story
works the same way lots of different
stories have lots of different aims
except that always um character
investment is what we're looking for
like how do you make people care about
the story they're watching and if you
can great if you don't then there's a
problem a foot that you can then try and
diagnose um it's it's like a medical
journal like we're trying to diagnose
problems there's there's a dozen
different ways a problem can manifest
and 100 different solutions um let's
find some um but yeah I don't I don't
really take much Relish in the in the
hatred side of the internet I don't
really like watching it I don't like
doing it unless it's Iron Fist in which
case I will tell you I hate this
thing with a passion um but also how
okay how could this have been better you
know what what are a couple of different
paths to a version of this thing that
might have
worked I think that it's only helpful
when you're trying to to to become
better at the work otherwise it is just
it's hatred for hatred sake and that way
lies
Madness
um what about you bman I um I don't uh
thankfully get critiqued online too much
I get most of the hate I've gotten for
the audio and things on the show has
died down uh but uh I do see this a lot
in like Yelp reviews you know like uh I
had somebody come in and be like uh says
can on the front door but they don't
have mesel here uh one
star and it's like okay like if you
actually read the review it's like
whatever but that one star keeps
lowering us on Yelp and makes us less
searchable and um and so after opening
the bar I found that I want to crap on
people like I don't ever read reviews on
restaurants and things um
because I'm always like I know how much
effort I put into scum and villainy and
how much we care um so like am I going
to go to like the guy down the street
and and on him because like the
server I
had girlfriend broke up with him earlier
that day um and he was having a bad
night um so when I have to talk about
something that I
despise uh I will say something like um
you know the scene where R2-D2 and Luke
are talking in the Millennium Falcon in
R2-D2 plays the Hologram of Princess
Leia uh I really loved that scene
because like while yes it was pure fan
service it also evoked an emotion in the
in me as a fan and it's the same emotion
that it would have invoked in Luke and
it brought me closer to my hero and then
that and then I don't have to say my
real thoughts on The Last Jedi you
know uh you know so I try to find like
two things that I really
enjoyed about the thing that I didn't
like cuz there's always something like
you don't like Iron Fist but like
remember the time that Jessica Jones
showed up on the show or whatever that
was cool right um like I I hate book of
Boba Fett but that the minute when it
turns into the Mandalorian again in
that's kind of cool yeah so it's just
like oh my God episode 5 was some of the
best Boba Fett I've ever seen he wasn't
in that episode yeah but when they
fought with the dark saber and the
Mandalorian cut all those people up at
the beginning of episode 5 wasn't that
great um so you just kind of talk around
the parts you don't like uh because
there's always something right there's
always something in everything that's
that you can say something nice about
the lighting was
great I Jason Muse one of my favorite
things about Jason Muse was has always
been that he finds the good and
everything the dude's never you know
read a bad comic book like back in the
day we'd be like oh man we'd give him
like the books that we didn't want give
him like your run of Sonic disruptors
from Marvel and
like take these and then he'd read
them and he'd be like what you think
waiting for him to be like this sucks
and he was just like oh that was awesome
and you're like why and he's like oh it
was in color
like crazy low and still is so Charming
like he's never a person that's like oh
Disney's lost its way or what
happened to Marvel and he's just
like what superheroes I can't
believe they make them in movies I
didn't have them growing up
like um and that's I like to take a page
out of his book like I just can't get
into you
know dissertations about how something
could have been better and like
it's my job
yeah a one I'm the one that's like I'm I
you know like oh my God that was in
color like they used all four colors on
that comic book
[Laughter]
amazing um what do we
got uh all right last one
um Jeff Becker wants to know what scene
did you always want in a movie that you
never got and then he says I always
wanted the 3 to five minute vignette of
Bruce Wayne training with all of his
teachers to become
Batman oh so like you know dard and and
Zar zatara and everybody that razal
ghoul and
yeah
um
sure what scene do we never
get you know I've seen a lot of Batman
and you never see his parents
die um they call it Crime Alley I've
only ever seen one crime in it where's
the rest of the
crime why not murder alley makes a lot
more sense that one time two people got
shot
Ally um one what do I like that I've not
seen them
do
H you know I mean like I I I love when
they let him
detect and we've seen him do more of
that as the movies have gone on in terms
of a b of Batman I'm trying to think
like because generally in order to
answer this question it would be like
you're matching Source material versus
when it's brought to another medium am I
correct I guess but it could be you
know like what happens after Smokey and
the Bandit and frog drive off after they
deliver the cores you know yeah I want
to see some in that
TransAm that's what iume they're going
to earn that turkey I was eight when I
saw it but I assumed they were all
like is there a part of the story that
you you know it's it's like that bit
that we were talking about Rogue one
like when I was like you know oh
maybe Jin erso is the pilot in the in
the TIE fighter that knocks into
Vader and sends him off his axis like
there's that version of it that's
great not what we saw not what they did
but you know I still I still like to
imagine that that's a part of that movie
even though it
isn't um how about uh I you know what I
would take a movie about the missing 18
years in Jesus's
life right like they track him up till
12 and then they pick him up when he's
30 seems like you skipped the best
part I know it's like what am I doing
with all this hair on my body
exactly you know urges
all teens the entire John Hughes C
catalog they missed you can totally do
you know the Jesus Diaries Jesus Christ
day off yeah just show all those
years what went on in those Missing
Years um that and let me see
um something that I've loved that
they've turned into something else but
I've like oh but they left this
out h
I would have I don't know if this quite
answers the question but how cool and
like I've seen the deleted footage I
just mean how cool would the waa attack
on Echo base have been if they had been
able to execute it like that scene like
everybody's like I love Empire it's so
dark but like dropping a 3 to five
minute monster movie at the beginning
right before the Empire attacks on Hoth
like how cool would that have been I I
feel like we all would enjoy
that that's
truth yeah I mean there's there's also
that bit that somebody put in a comic
book either a comic book was just
somebody threw it together as a page and
put it up on the internet but it's of
Darth Vader in Cloud City going to where
all of like c3po's pieces are after he
gets like sort of scattered apart by the
the creatures in there like and
that bit where he picks up the head and
looks at it and it's Darth Vader
remembering that he built C3PO
and like he had been his constant
companion throughout most of his life
and now he's in pieces and he's the one
who asks the the druing ugots or
whatever to put him back together again
you know like that bit of a boy still
remembering the pieces of his childhood
that he thought was dead sparked by just
like this is mine like how did it come
back to me like never never thought that
would happen in a million years but he's
here again is anybody seeing this I
built this Droid son of a I I did this
when I worked for w like that's how long
ago we're going do you know who W is
that's how long I was a slave you guys
yeah and I built this Droid and now he's
here again this is this is no
coincidence this is I built this in a
cave um if we're going to do that if
we're GNA look at Star Wars things that
never happened I of course would love to
see the dinner on Cloud City oh yeah you
know once the doors open and Han
Solo does one of the coolest
things in cinema history sees Darth
Vader and his first instinct is to
shoot him
dead like you know he's like his
budd's like oh we just made a deal it's
going to keep the Empire out of this
place forever and is essentially
like saying oh we just just made a deal
to keep you know the Nazis out
of here forever and then the door opens
and they're like it's Hitler his first
instinct is to shoot him to gun
him down and were not for the fact that
you know Vader's got the magic and
where he's like it would have been like
that that the movie's end right there
like holy The Smuggler shot
space Hitler isn't that nuts like these
movies are done it's crazy but he don't
do it and then
there but then they also have to have
dinner together like the whole time
Darth Vader's like you tried to
shoot me like don't make small talk you
literally pulled a gun out and tried to
shoot me were I not magic I would have
been shot and I'm pretty sure you're my
daughter he's like no you should eat
you're going to be frozen for a very
long time please eat up eat up don't
wait for
me I don't mean to take make this night
off all about me but I found a Droid
that I built when I was a kid in the
garbage room like what's going on man um
I'm pretty sure that I told you this
story but like I had gotten approached
by an editor at I guess it's tour or
maybe it's random house or whatever it
was but the people who publish the Star
Wars from a certain point of view books
and each of them is like an anthology
about like pick a scene that we never
saw like one side of or or just an idea
of a thing that could have been in a
movie that never was and so I pitched
them the dinner scene but from the
perspective of the chef like that
Lando has gotten the best of the
best and he hired a chef who's about to
serve her most important dinner she's
ever going to serve the Sith
lord of the Galaxy is here I've got to
plan a dinner service for this
and it's her entire like
this is the meal she's one she's the
Bear right like I'm about to serve the
meal that'll Define this restaurant on
and all she hears like she's got her
staff working her CDC is working the guy
who makes sauces is working she's got a
menu planned and all right they're here
and she hears a laser
blast but they sit down and start eating
and so they or they bring food out that
nobody touches because the princess lady
is angry the handsome guy is
Happy Darth Vader can't eat anything and
I plan the goddamn menu for him he never
takes the helmet off and it's all from
her perspective and the end of the story
is Vader comes back to the kitchen to
pay his respects to the chef because the
last thing she makes is a very humble
dessert that she learned to cook when
she was a gutter rat on corusant
that's just like red pudding like a
basic like butter and and milk
and and bread and he has his Ratatouille
moment where he's like he has his
Ratatouille moment it's the here's what
I used to eat when I was a
young Jedi banging around corusant
learning like this is what made me
feel at home and I can smell it but I
can't taste it and you've you've
reminded me of the person that I thought
I was going to be and I'm not so my
compliments to the chef and I wrote this
story and like sent it in and they're
like well we you know we have another
story set in the kitchen I was like you
should not have green let me to write
this story he's like well you can change
almost all of it and we can write it I
was like no I'm good I think I like this
version of it and I just still
have it on a hard drive of like the most
important the biggest dinner ever on
cloud city um about that because like
they sit back down after Han Solo sh
always been the thing that like
captures my imagination is the doors
Clos and it's like they actually have a
meal because like as a kid I was like
does he take his helmet
off that would creep everyone out even
worse just like
can't keep it in and spilling and
whatnot they're like he's a Messy eater
got feeding
tube I I think I've said this on the
show before what what uh so Han Solo's
going down into Carbonite right and uh
and Chewbacca goes nuts screaming
yelling and uh Boba Fett goes to shoot
Chewbacca and Vader knocks his gun down
why 3pos on Chewbacca's
back now obviously that's my Droid that
I built don't shoot that remember my
Droid I told you about it at dinner
um I like that I think um there's
also for with the dinner like you know
there could be somebody who's just like
here's your chance to
kill like everything that's wrong with
the Galaxy like you're making this
food poison it and she's like oh
I can't do that because you know or he
whatever the I take pride in my
chefing or whatever the and they're
like no this is our chance and they make
a against that first Chef's will
they get some poison food in
there but like V don't
eat and then it's like you know
they most of the leftovers go to the
ugot and some poor ugot bites
it I got to put the story online like I
wrote it you should I I wonder
we should like produce it as like a smom
or something it could totally be a
cartoon
right let's do it as long as we
don't sell it it can be anything let's
do it we know some talented
people we some folks who do some uh
the other fun one would be um
the me the the humans that went to Endor
before the rebels that the Ewoks
at cuz you know they didn't Han wasn't
their first trip down the barbecue path
right so like who was like we're go like
uh you know like Ewoks the battle for
Endor like the prequel except like the
Ewoks eat them they sent Big's dark
lighter there on a
mission and he got eaten yeah they send
Porkins don't send Porkins yeah go feed
them for
years you're too yummy
Porkins um did we do them all that's two
questions look at that
is that it is that the end of the
show that's a show if we want it to be
or we can just hang out as we
want to do
[Laughter]
we can um man like we just ran out
of
show you got no news I've said all the
things that I've
seen I guess so anybody in chat did we
miss anything was there a trailer that
we didn't talk
about um is there any super chats we
missed yeah I don't see anybody offering
up any
somebody super chatted
earlier do you guys know the punk band
propagandhi guess there's a punk I sure
would like to named propagandhi and some
guy did a super he said it like four
times he did a Super Chat and he said
you look just like JC looks or B man
looks just like the singer from
propagandhi so I pulled some photos do
you want to say yes or no do you think I
look like you guys have seen me in real
life too so I guess it's just this flat
2D version of me look like uh this
guy the middle guy in the white or this
I don't have pecs like that
but put a shirt
off do you think I look like that I
don't see it could be his brother I
don't see it too much that's a little
closer it could be
related
yeah um in chat they're saying William
Anderson says Nicholas Holt is Lex
Luther yes we didn't discuss that
apparently Nicholas Holt uh the Beast
has been hired to play Lex Luthor who at
one point we were told he was
auditioning for Superman as well he's
our new Lux Luthor yay he watch um
righteous gemstones do you see have you
ever seen that show no but I know that I
don't know him personally but I like
that kid they hired as Jimmy Olsen he
was
yeah oh was he he was excellent in
booksmart um so yeah I'm all for that
kid he's talented oh yeah The
Madame web trailer have you seen oh
Evans yes where she's like um it's
morbin time
yeah like uh he a guy that used to work
with my mom before she died when she was
studying spiders spiders she died jungle
it's like an incredible line that's like
wow that and she made it work well
almost um yeah but but I still I'm not
quite sure what's going on with that
movie no to see the other spider
costumes but it looks like they play for
like two seconds in the movie I think we
saw all of the
costume um let's see what else people
are talking about did we talk about
Godzilla well we talked about the
Monarch monarch
uh Invincible we haven't seen it yet
we're getting to it yeah haven't seen
the killer yet I need to make some time
for that the killer the the um oh yeah
what's his face um Fincher yeah um fast
Bender tap sequel we talked about that a
little
bit
um Jonathan Ramirez 574 says make Vader
kill the chef though for reminding him
of the person that he should be and how
far he's drifted from the boy he was
he's taking your story and running with
it nice
[Laughter]
try um let's
see I'm checking chat to see if there's
anything we miss talking
about dream scenario was the name of the
Nick Cage
movie dream
scenario kid loved it did you um Mark
did you see the meme that people were
sharing where it was like uh I guess CHR
Pine said something about like yeah I
think we'll probably do another Dungeons
and Dragons movie and somebody took that
and ran with it and they were like
please make a Dungeons and Dragons movie
like every 18 months but do it like the
Fast and the Furious so every movie it's
like a D and D campaign that keeps going
where like they level up and they level
up and they level up until the 10th
movie they're essentially gods and they
can do whatever they want just like in
Fast and the Furious
for that I think bees watch the out
of that it's like I'm a level three bar
but when I'm a level 10 bar my
charisma's off the chain and I
can summon angels with my Harps Accord
hell yeah uh Kabuki kid asked did we
talk about bodies yet yeah last week and
Mark talked a little bit about it this
week because he's catching up and what'
you say about it you were like yeah yeah
like I dig it like the the the core con
seit is strong
um and I'm I'm curious to know where it
goes
um Tyler Hall wants to
know what happened in my big TV big ass
TV during the move um it's still here it
moved and then it moved back it's
upstairs we took it from our bedroom
though put it in the living room and now
I have to get a um what is it when you
don't plug in to the normal but you need
a
different plug because it's like this we
need more power oh you have like a it's
like a 240 volt or 220 volt or something
own electrical output that's not up
there so we're waiting to have that put
in um well I I think that's it man I
think I'm looking into the chat and
seeing if we missed can I tell you Zack
Fields wh if I can say anything about
the M Windu stuff coming
soon I'm just I've seen pencils for
three of the four issues I've seen
colors and letters for the first issue I
looks great it was so much fun to do um
you know maybe there's more Star Wars in
my future maybe there isn't I can't say
but come late January early February you
can see issue one of uh Star Wars mace
windy huzzah that's your book that's the
book
baby um Mark working for for the
for the actual Empire man working
getting a check to work on Star Wars
stuff most of us work on Star Wars stuff
for free just talking about it and
keeping star Mark's keeping Star Wars
alive and they give him money for it
yeah thoughts on Wonka haven't seen it
yet but today the review embargo I think
seemed to lift and uh and all of
everything that I've heard is like it's
delightful like Shalom is great and the
movie is super fun and light and
energetic and the songs are good and
it's
funny I'm still having trouble wrapping
my head around a Wily Wonka that doesn't
actively want to see children die which
is the Gan Wilder version when he grew
up when he grew up he was like you know
what I've done it all and I've seen it
all now I just want to see kids die
because I'd be up he's like
sometimes I just cut myself to make to
see if I could he anymore yeah like what
happens between Wonka And Willie Wonka
in the Chocolate Factory like when did
the children hurt him the boy's like oh
no stop please you make candy for kids
for like 50 years get to a place
where you're like everybody
ungrateful bastards them kids as
the internet
says um let's
see I think we've yeah nobody's going
you didn't talk about this you didn't
talk about that so I guess
we we've hit everything we've done
it did you guys see did you guys see uh
I have not seen it I was sent an early
cut and uh I did not get a chance to see
it you are in it um the disturbance in
of disturbance in the force the
documentary on theot of the
bar a lot of interviews was shot right
at uh at scum and villainy
right yeah we shot uh Bonnie Burton
former Lucas film employee there and
Seth Green and uh nice couple other guys
can't wait to see it's about the Star
Wars Christmas Special yeah it was done
by
um yeah the guy who did Napoleon
Dynamite and
um Kyle Newman who did Fanboys worked on
it and uh
Goldberg supposed to be great can't wait
to see it they showed me when they were
filming he brought in like an original
script an original story boards and
stuff that he had collected it was
pretty
cool in uh chat um off axis says I've
been an extra on the flash in Vancouver
British Columbia when you brought us all
food that was a happy memory that
reminded me I used to go out and buy
food and give out hamburgers yeah I do
love that story Good Times
um well there it is kids I'm looking for
anything we might missed but we pretty
much seems like we hit everything we did
we did somebody asked in harness the
dark teaser trailer uh I guess W
division's coming out on
Blu-ray yeah I think we talked about
that did they're starting to like w
Division and Loki season one and Falcon
Winter Soldier I think I the trailer or
a little behind the scenes making of
thing that shows you know what her new
show looks a little little bit like and
I guess you see Aubrey Plaza for the
first time whoever she's playing um
somebody asked in chat if I've seen if
I've heard about the new Jeffrey Wright
movie American fiction what's that um
it's a it's a the directorial debut of
cord Jefferson who won an Emmy for
writing the black and white Nostalgia
episode of
Watchmen um he wrote and directed a
movie starring Jeffrey Wright as a black
author struggling with uh sort of
identity and class and is he black
enough to be a black author is he not
black enough to be in that SP like it's
it's an interesting movie I saw it about
a month ago um it won like the audience
award in Toronto and it's been playing
festivals and cleaning up and there's
Oscar talk for Jeffrey Wright and um
it's it's a really interesting movie
very well done um super funny Sterling
ke Brown is in it um
um Isa re is in it yeah no I I dug it
very much if it comes to a town near you
you should see it it's very it's very
engaging I me interesting and I'm sure
you'll get a screener because it's it's
that kind of movie in chat John franois
says thoughts on Chris Evans Avengers
comments what did he say he said
something to the effect of
um he he doesn't love being in those
movies he's like listen I loved playing
you know Steve Rogers um it did you know
wonders for me but like you show up on
set you might do two pages of dialogue
for eight hours of being onet and
there's a thousand angles and he's like
this pain Hustlers movie or whatever
that he did for Netflix is like yeah
we're doing nine pages of dialogue a day
like you're moving it feels like you're
making a thing it's a it's a real
character that you can dig into and
every day of work you feel like you you
work today he's like there's a version
of my career he's like that I made these
smaller interesting movies that nobody's
seen like in the interviewer talked
about sunshine the Danny Bo's you know
science fiction movie he's like I love
that movie he's one of my favorite
movies ever made nobody's seen it
there's a version of my career where
people saw that and blew up and they
cast me as a character actor as a you
know a person who gets to kind of dig
into stuff he's like but I'm Steve
Rogers and that's fine like it's made my
life incredibly livable and I love the
effect of that character on the world
and I enjoy those movies quite a bit but
as a creat ative Endeavor from his chair
it's like it's not that fulfilling for
me it's like and you know I get it I
100% get it like he doesn't relish it um
in a way that he relishes just I'm gonna
do this tiny thing I'm gonna do
Snowpiercer he was so good in that um
Galactic J says hey Kev when is your new
film dropping Kevin not till the fall
the 4:30 movie but uh next week we're
actually doing a pickup uh shot for the
movie that we couldn't do back in Jersey
when we made the movie we had to be out
here for it so uh we're we're doing
a a thing so um and
I yeah it's there's it's so early this
movie don't come out till the fall so
everyone's begging me to keep my mouth
shut um on the production side they're
like don't start we're too far out and
like that all right but some cool
things are happening to the movie right
now I like are a foot yeah JC's seen it
JC has to work he's forced to work on it
all the
time when we're done here he'll be doing
something yeah with soon as the show
ends I'm
doing John Francois in chat wants to
know why was Splinter not accepted at
San Diego ComicCon um we didn't enter
the San Diego ComiCon Film Festival um
instead we opted to do a panel where we
screened it had a Q&A
so like on the one hand sure it wasn't
accepted there on the other hand they
accepted us and gave us a panel so um
hey win-win um somebody asked me if I
was doing uh th Awards season stuff this
year I'm not uh if you want to know more
you can come to scum and villain and
I'll tell you in person that's how you
say
positive buy me a
beer buy yourself a beer and I tell you
the story
yeah um wild Samurai says he's wanted
out since Winter Soldier of talking
about Chris Evans you ain't kidding man
when I was on The Tonight Show
couch with him I was like oh man you're
getting ready to make the second one
like he excited he's like
no he was not he was not big into it but
at that point he was talking about like
they might let they might let me direct
one day so he was like I'll keep with it
uh and I think it's it's the version of
the Brewbaker story like if you do those
movies then it unlocks to a certain
degree latitude on the other side of it
like you're Captain America
you've made the money you're beloved by
an audience and now you can hopefully
bring that audience to the other
that you want to do um he just now needs
to choose the things that excite him and
hopefully he does you know it's it's
Daniel Radcliffe like his first movies
out where Harry Potter he can do
anything
and he is he's like I'm GNA be a
corpse in this weird ass Swiss Army Man
movie I'm going to be Weird Al I'm going
to do this horns thing with Joe Hill
like he's he's making really interesting
choices because he can or Michael B
Jordan yeah I can do whatever I want
it's The Paton thing I'm I'm gonna do
whatever the I want because I made
nine Twilight movies for you Joe Hill is
that Stephen King's
kid I just found out recently that he
was the boy in Creep Show is he the one
know who's using the voodoo doll
his dad putting the pins in his his dad
his dad's like that's what God made
fathers
babe that's that's Joe Hill wow I mean
i' I heard I think I watched that on
a um Joe Blow video or what the fck this
movie video but I was like what how did
I
not he's good little actor back in the
day good for you Joe Hill
yeah um what else we got I guess that's
it I think that's it you got any cons
left for the rest of the year or you
done I got are you going to La Comic Con
next week I'm not I'll be in I'll be in
San Francisco that that weekend I'm
gonna be there on Sunday I'm doing a
panel um with
uh what is it them I think it's hold on
me look it up real
quick Sunday Sunday Sunday Sunday the
American Cancer Society at LACC so I'm
going to be hosting a panel about I
believe I I don't quote me but I think
uh some survivors
who take it to the comic book medium um
so that'll be that'll be my uh La Comic
Con that's coming up uh I don't think I
have any appearances until
um do I no we had to cancel everything
for SM castle and stuff yeah January
comes roaring back to life with lots of
activities and stuff gotta
excellent
I guess that's it man I think
that's show how's Jen doing ask tension
Rider I talked about earlier in the show
she's doing well doctor says like her
x-ray looks great
and um her wound looks amazing you know
Jennifer today was like I measured the
scar I was like how big is it she's like
eight inches I was like wellow and
replaced your hip I mean they got to get
in there I know don't tell David
cronberg though yeah
can I take a picture of it exactly
I'm gonna write a whole movie about this
we're GNA start your
scar Tom jeppi points out 30th
anniversary of CL pretty soon yes 2024
is the full yearlong anniversary of
Clerks 30 years of Clerks um January
marks the 30th anniversary of us going
to Sundance and the movie getting picked
up and uh October uh will Mark the 30th
Anniversary since it came out in
theaters instead so all throughout 2024
you'll be hearing about that and you'll
also be hearing about if it's the 30th
anniversary of cler's why then it must
also be 30 years of J and Silent
Bob so you'll be hearing a lot more
about that from me because kids I don't
own clerks um somebody else paramont at
this point but me and Jay sure as
own Jay and Silent Bob
so if we're gonna celebrate anything
it's GNA be the thing that that's
ours I feel like that's uh somebody
should write the story of that deal
carving out Jay and Silent Bob for
you that's a good one as I've told that
story many
times um oh kids please bring back Super
Chat next time what do you mean bring it
back did we not is it not open or
something it it was on it was on for the
first
half and then who turned it off I had
will turn it off because it was driving
me nuts do you want to leave it on I
just had curiosity
why uh
it the six people who love Super Chat
and then there's like a thousand people
who are like I hate this it derails the
show and makes things
impossible is it anything different than
answering questions like what we've just
been doing for the last few minutes
looking
at
chat I not really but a lot of people in
chat hate
it uh
plastic Jay and Sil and Bob is a special
place of my heart wrap up the show
guys fair enough I got you I got you
with some sugar now here's some
spice um well there it is kids you have
a good time yeah you did and if you
did you got to thank uh B man for
bringing us right into your homes
o um and IFH you like this show at all
well it ain't because of me because I
just like everything and whatnot it's
the Discerning writer um who had
the uh quote of the day what is it pitch
don't or don't pitch either
way
works remember kids don't pitch
you know it's so easy to point out a
hole hey there's a hole you know
what's even better fill that
hole don't bother
anybody just go back to your hole back
to your hole um give it up for
Mr Mark Bernard and ladies and gentlemen
52 years young today indeed I got 90
minutes and then I then I turn the clock
and I become an old person like double
ARP is already on my doorstep
like you were 90 minutes you better wake
up your lady man the last time she could
a 51 year old and not with
this back my
friend like no it's like a 60y
old because
[Laughter]
could you be vious he's like I
don't know what happened I married a
young man I don't know what the
happened who broke him
um Chad is lighting up with happy
birthday Mark right thank you everybody
so
sweet wish we could have been in person
and we all could have been drunk um but
alas January we'll be back in the bar
there's always January in the B and
we'll be back on a cruise where the
booze flows February kids if you haven't
signed up yet for Jane son Bob's Cru of
skew what are you waiting for good times
you're GNA watch Splinter on the boat
we're
Beyond on the boat we G do so many
things it's gonna be good times you're
doing a live reading of a thing on the
boat right right read M rats too the
script with Jason Lee and Ethan plea
right there and Jason others you can I
be in it yeah hell yeah we're gonna have
you read I mean I'm on the boat if
you're not programmed opposite us with
some panel and stuff there's so
many activities that like you know and
also they don't have like there's 3,000
people on the cruise when we set sail
but they don't have a 3,000 seat theater
so it's like you have to break up all
the shows and whatnot so they might
program us against each
other mailed I
know it
sheet sheet Joshua mundall says will Jen
be able to make the cruise I think
so I think so you can wheel her on right
if you have to she can just Lounge by
the the Leo
deck flying ace production says North
America is poror Kev that's what
we're waiting for oh believe me you
don't have to go on this Cruise
kids like it went of course but I you
this is not mandatory by any stretch of
the
imagination um I know money's weird
right
now so yeah believe me if you can't go
don't sweat it you're not
being can't be peer pressured onto a
boat if you can be it's not going to be
by me but if you've got some spare cash
and you're like I always wanted to be on
a boat with that has been silent
Bill well then here's your
opportunity going from Miami to the
Bahamas and then back again a three-day
tour a thre Day
Tour
um well there it
is my friend gathered we talked about
all the things
matter and now go enjoy your
week have a good one yeah be nice
to
somebody you heard him that's all he
wants for his birthday that's it be
nice to somebody there it is cheapest
gift you can get Mark Bernard y be nice
to somebody you don't have to be nice to
well now you're adding
it's like I it's nice to my kid so
you upstairs be nice to my wife and
be like I honored Mark first his
birthday I'm legally bound however G be
nice to some person I don't
necessarily
do good thing I like
everybody wild Samurai says Peter
Jackson wants us to wrap it
up we're not even at Oppenheimer time
yet kids no we haven't have we cracked
three hours not quite uh yeah we're at
we're at 3:15 3:15 all right it's all
over you Potato Heads um there it is my
friends that we'll be back again we'll
do it again before the end of the year
we will right yeah it's only November
yeah see no reason not to probably twice
um but until the next time kids
that is fat man
beyond uh for this week um I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernard tune in same fat
Time same fat Channel sm.com or
youtube.com kevinsmith Jeff's kiss
everybody happy birthday Mark thank you
Kev good night
everybody this is the greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA ask
keev anything every AA has a 10year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old up Kevin
Smith